Ja, ich mach gerade Stream an.
So, wunderbar, da sind wir wieder am Start, weiter geht's.
Die nächsten drei Easy-Wins würde ich sagen.
Los du schon?
Ah, ok.
Nice.
Wer nicht spielt, der kann nicht verlieren.
So, mal gucken, dass der Gramm nicht zu laut ist jetzt.
Das Game neigt ja dazu, teilweise aus dem Nichts übelst laut zu sein.
Wir müssen jetzt einfach, wir müssen jetzt einfach Dings machen hier.
Na, wie heißt?
Squad-Stream.
Boah, es ist laut.
Boah, es ist laut wieder.
So.
So, ich muss mich jetzt mal killen lassen, das neben mir ballert.
Ok Leute, Leute, killt mich mal, ich muss die Sound-Lautstärke gucken.
Ah, excellent, wunderbar.
Na, ich glaube, es passt.
Hat denn nicht einer von euch diesen BenQ-Monitor, der mit...
Ah.
Ja, weil mich würde mal interessieren, ob dieser Dark-Black-Boost oder wie das heißt, ob das irgendwas bringt oder ob das einfach nur Marketing-Bullshit ist.
Ja, das ist mehr Marketing, weil den hat mein BenQ das auch, also es bringt schon ein bisschen was, aber...
Ja, mein ASUS hier hat das halt auch.
Das heißt dann bloß anders.
Ja man, Black-Boost.
Ah, ich glaube, ich muss...
Aber ich kann sagen, das ist schon Baba.
Ja, das...
Ja, das dachte ich mir, dachte ich mir.
Deswegen wollte ich, deswegen habe ich mir jetzt ja auch mal bestellt.
Also ich glaube schon, aber irgendwie...
Oh, raus.
Also, man kann durchaus auch mit 144 spielen, also nicht das Problem.
Ja, aber ist das so krass?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also...
Also, wenn ich jetzt CS spiele, auf meinen 144 und würde danach auf meinen 42 integrieren, das ist...
Ja, bei CS hast du ja auch den Vorteil, das Game läuft ja auch gut.
Hier, also in Warzone, Warzone ist scheiße.
Ja, ich werde aus dem Lufttag...
Ah, ey.
Ah, also ich weiß nicht, ob das in Warzone, also Warzone ist schon nicht so performant.
Ich bin vor dir, ich...
Der ist hinter mir...
Ich fange die Schüsse ab.
Ihr wollt jetzt nicht Superstore landen oder sowas, oder?
Jaja, ich glaube, der ist hinter uns.
Der war halt auch so tief, weil er mich nur am lasern ist.
Ich habe eine Platte für dich gefangen.
Hier.
Oha.
Oden, jawoll.
Der da oben, der da hier, der ist alleine.
Okay.
Der wird jetzt geodent.
Ich habe nichts, was er in die Gubbel verschießt.
Ich hoffe, dass er jetzt alleine ist, dass er nicht alleine noch irgendwo auftauscht.
Ah, ich habe vom Multiplier noch Leute.
Er kommt hier unter mir, er steckt unter mir.
Ich bin noch nicht da.
Komm mit auf Shotgun um die Ecke, der wird jetzt easy wrecked.
Okay, alles.
Kannst du noch mal drauf gehen?
Ja.
Der ist in der Tankstelle unten drin.
Ich bin da, ich bin da.
Wow.
Von der Seite hat er mich angeschossen.
Irgendwo von drauf.
Hier.
Warum bin ich jetzt da unten?
Vielleicht hatte ich von der Seite, von der Seite, oder?
Dahinten, dahinten ist noch einer.
Nicht hier, bitte.
Dahinten an der A.
Hast du den anderen?
Nee, nee.
Zapf, Säule 6, 2 Nudelkohl.
Oh, oh, oh.
Die Nade in der Tankstelle, die sind richtig irre.
Der hat aber gute Hits.
Ich glaube, da pusht uns einer gerade.
Was muss ich eigentlich kommen?
Was macht der da eigentlich?
Die haben da Stress angefangen halt.
Zapf, Säule 6.
Also die haben gut, die haben gut Damage drin da drüben.
Die können wir pushen.
Moment mal.
Armour Break, Armour Break.
Einer.
Hier.
Hier ist so gut.
Spiele bei mir.
Nee.
Hier ist noch einer.
Alter.
Hier ist ja richtig Stress, Alter.
Massive Stress.
Wir brauchen ein paar Platten.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Von wo?
Wo bist du?
Nee, ich lieg relativ safe in der Ecke.
Hast du die anderen ab?
Jetzt pushen, sie pushen von vorne.
Sie pushen von der Tankstelle aus.
Aber wir waren wieder so krass gesplittet.
Wie kann das sein?
Nee, nee.
Die sind aus Deutschland rausgekommen.
Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Aber hier war auch einer mitten in den Storage.
Die sind überall.
Die Deathmatch.
Wir waren eigentlich nicht wirklich krass gesplittet.
Nur einer war weg.
Der eine kam halt überraschenderweise von hinten.
Ich hör nix.
Ja, das passiert.
Hast Platte reingepflanzt.
Vielleicht.
Nee, ich hab die andere nicht absichtlos so leise.
Ich hab die extra lauter gemacht.
Oha.
Muss ich schreien?
Wir können drauflaufen.
What the fuck?
Komm, lass drauflaufen.
Warte kurz, dass Max den Gulasch gewinnt.
Kann ich den schon mal holen?
Ja, hol ihn.
What the hell?
Manchmal verstehe ich die Fights nicht.
Ja, Mann.
Das war so schlecht.
Das ist Minecraft, ja.
Moin, wie läuft's hier?
Wir haben schon drei Wins heute.
Aber ich hab zwischenzeitlich mal ausgemacht im Stream.
Ich glaube, ich mach gleich noch mal aus und schnell auf Grafikkarten-encoding um.
Oh, ich bin ja wieder da.
Mach ihn auf, mach ihn auf.
Ich komm direkt runter bei euch.
Boah, der drückt direkt Steuern um.
Der ist tot.
Ich hab gar nichts.
Mit der slidet mein Loot weg.
Wenn jemand ein Sniper will, den liegt ganz hinten.
Leerlager markiert.
Jawoll, der sagt man doch nicht nein.
Ich muss mal wieder snipern.
Willst du die haben, dann nimm du die.
Du sagst, hilf mir, ich mach den.
Während ich den mach, kommst du schon angeslided in den Loot rein.
Nein, ich hab den mit der Usi.
Boah, bei mir war's.
Oh, bei mir, bei mir auch.
Der pusht bei mir um die Ecke hier.
Ich geh hoch.
Leerlager markiert.
Einer down.
Noch mehr, noch mehr, noch mehr hier.
In der Mitte.
Ich muss hier immer...
Ein hat... Teamwipe, Teamwipe.
Sehr schön.
Das ist richtig entspannt hier immer.
Super entspannt, ja.
Oh, die hatten schön Kohle, die hatten schön Kohle.
Erstmal alles gesaugt.
Ich hab sogar den Frag für einen bekommen, den du da hinten angeduscht hast und noch.
Kohle, Kohle, Kohle wie Kronk.
Was kaufen wir?
Jetzt lassen wir Box kaufen.
Was? Einen Box kaufen, einen Box.
Das Klettersystem, Alter.
Die anderen kommen in eine Minute.
Ich hab kein Geld.
Ich komm, ich komm, ich komm.
Ich geb dir alles, was ich hab.
Das reicht, den machst du nicht.
Ich kauf' platt.
Erstmal das Geld rausgepinkelt, jetzt sieht es immer so aus.
Flup, Flup, Flup.
Hier Communityplatten.
Hey, damit er erst mal meine Munikiste genommen hat.
Ich haus auf die... Ach du heilige.
Geh'n dir die Munikiste.
Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein komisches Ding?
Ja, hast du die Munikiste aber gedroppt? Nee, ne?
Nee, ich kann hier nicht dropen, leider.
Okay, let's go.
Ich hab immer noch Platte, bitte.
Soll ich kaufen? Ja.
Moin Leute, schön, dass so viele da sind.
Ist die Lautstärke von den Teammates jetzt okay?
Flughafen, okay.
Nee, lass sichern.
Ja, ja, ja, ist besser.
Da kommen vielleicht eh irgendwo Teams her.
Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen Coal, um ein paar Killstreaks und ULV-Gedöns zu kaufen.
Jawollo.
Heute ruhiger Stream.
Denkt immer gleich an hier.
Oh man, das ist auf Gottseid weg.
Aber da liegt unser nächster Drop.
Excellent.
Aber der ist noch alleine.
Der ist echt alleine.
Ja, ich hab nur einen Group.
Full Trust, Moritz, Full Trust.
Haben wir hier irgendwas noch?
Ähm...
Lauf hier nicht außen.
Diese Irren von der Lagerhalle da an der Tankstelle.
Hatten wir schon mit denen Konfrontation?
Ich meine, ja.
Die Irren von der Lagerhalle.
PM.
Die hab ich nicht mal in den Kopf gesehen.
Was soll ich holen?
Kannste machen, ich spiel halt immer UMP und Grau.
UMP.
Ich spiel Sniper, ich spiel auch Sniper aggressiv.
Ich mach aber mehr Damage mit der Sniper eigentlich.
Warte, wo kommt das Ding mit?
Wo steht das denn?
Ach, das ist da oben.
Ich kacke nur, Alter.
Hä?
Hier oben noch irgendwas schöne.
Ah.
Oder doch nicht?
Okay, ist doch nicht oben.
Nein, das ist eins weiter unten.
Ja, eins weiter unten.
Big Brain.
Hauslayout.
Okay.
Also, Airfield-Puzzle ist nicht so das Gute, oder?
Folgt mir meine Söhne.
Oh.
Hä?
Ja.
Ich bin reich und schön.
Auf geht's, MW2-Wipes.
Da fliegen Schüsse, ey.
Da fliegen wirre Schüsse.
Was wollen wir kaufen? Hier liegt noch Platteratini.
Ich bin voll.
Eine Kaufstation.
Soll ich was kaufen?
Wir haben ein bisschen Geld.
Also, eine Drohne, ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich kann noch Geld legen, wenn ihr auch noch was kaufen wollt.
Da oben ist noch Kiste.
Ja, wir können noch eine Drohne kaufen hier.
Ich leg mal meine Kohle davor.
Ja, warte.
Dann koch ich einfach noch eine.
Ja.
Hier liegt eine Drohne.
Ich hab noch ein...
...Muni-Board.
Ah.
Meiner vielleicht.
Der hier.
Der spielt mit normalem Laser.
So auch.
Also, auf der Map zieht man ja mal wieder nichts.
Ja.
Meistens in der nächsten Minute, nach der Aussage...
Ist nichts, ja.
Lass mal nochmal so einen Aufpack machen.
Dann kommen die entweder, oder wir wissen, wo der Infilt ist.
Rein in den Flughafen-Friedhof.
Rein in den Chat.
Wo in jedem Korpus ein Ziel liegen kann.
Und sogar, dass ich so schnell mit meiner Klaue bin.
Und so windig.
Deswegen spiel ich echt so eine MP gerade nebenher.
Man holt schneller auf, auch wenn man ein bisschen dahinter ist.
Wenn man MP rausholt, ist man gleich wieder da.
Die liegt sehr gut, die Zone.
Für diesen Aufpack.
Hier ist 100 Prozent irgendeine Ecke, wenn da irgendeiner da rumsitzt.
Ja, dass alle schön gegroupt sind.
Aber wie oft haben die eigentlich dieses Haus von Strapi da reingeballert?
Weil hier ist ja die eigentliche Map.
Glaubst du, die erfinden da tausend Häuser neu, oder was?
Nein, nein, gar nicht.
Aber ich mein, die haben ja...
Ja, die haben Strapi da reingeballert.
Und dann haben sie das Haus geballert.
Strapi hat da reingeballert.
Und haben dann außenrum noch random die Häuser hingeballert, nochmal.
Ja, man kann ja nicht mehr erwarten, oder?
Die sind... Bei dem Game Up, das ist schon mehr als genug.
Das ist eine tolle Halle, weil die hat nur einen Eingang durch das große, fette Tor.
Und da hinten die kleine Tür.
Ah, ich hab keine Platte.
Äh, ich hab voll Platten.
Brauch jemand noch Platten?
Nö.
Außen mit Rucksack.
Nee, Rucksack hab ich keinen.
Halle, ab in die Halley rein.
Ja.
Ja, Halley klingt echt gut, ne?
Sollen wir da hingehen?
Aber wir sollten noch nicht direkt rein.
Weil dann sitzen wir entweder wieder drei Stunden rum und es passiert nichts.
Oder wir werden sinnlos von der Seite weg.
Action, immer Action, immer Action.
Dann auf gehts, Kopfgeld, wo bist du?
Wo bist du?
Nicht mit dem Halley jetzt, bei der Zeit.
Dann haben wir noch noch Action.
Aber wohin willst du denn mit dem Halley?
Äh...
Zum Trophy ist es den Megan auch.
Vielleicht auch nicht schlecht, ne?
Haben wir einen Trophy am Halley?
Nicht drauf, ich hab eins, aber...
Oh guck mal, Doppelsicherungsauftrag rechts.
Nee, nee, komm, wir machen den also.
Nee, also ich mein, das wurde gesichert.
Achso.
Hab weggecrapped hier.
Ja, ja, ja, da seh ich mich.
Hier fliegt auch eine.
Gehen wir da hin?
Also hin fliegen.
Ja holt mich mal ab.
Oder holt uns mal ab hier.
Können wir da nicht durchlaufen?
Das ändert wieder in Zone-Camp, oder?
Achtung mit dem Schild.
Aber wir lassen...
Wir suchen die und dann werden wir uns gut positionieren, um die wegzumachen.
Boah.
Äh, Junge, ich hab hier erst mal zwei Platten Hit, Alter.
Die wissen es, die wissen es.
Oben auf dem Berg hier.
Ich seh keinen.
Ach, da unten, ne?
Sollen wir hier hin?
Zu grün, zu grün.
Zu grün.
Ja, die sind an Gelb.
Wo ist einer?
Der ist direkt bei mir.
Ich werf den Halley auf die...
Den die nie kommen, den die nie kommen.
Hier drin einer.
Hier drin.
Nice.
War der aber nicht.
Hier sind bestimmt noch mehr.
Oh, scheiße, wir haben den armen Typen da.
Der wollte eigentlich nur warten.
Der wollte doch nur überleben.
Und dann kommt da so ein 4er, Alter.
Zugriffsquad, Alter.
Also bei Gelb sind die irgendwo.
Ich glaub, das hier oben bei dem Hügel...
Ja, wir sind in der VW drin.
Versuchst du mit der, wo wir gelandet sind.
Ich will Platten kaufen.
Platten, ich kann dir welche geben.
Oh, vor uns, close eigentlich.
Leute, wir müssen schon da zusammenhin poschen.
Ja, warte.
Ich flank mal.
Aber du flankst über offen das Feld, wenn du links rückst.
Ach, was.
Kein Problem.
Der eine oben hat den Mega, die hits.
Oh, von hinten.
Was?
Wo?
Ich weiß nicht, von hinten halt.
Verrück mich nicht.
Doch, ich hab von hinten einen Hit bekommen.
Ich hab einen Sniper-Hit bekommen von hinten.
Ich seh nix, wo sind die?
Oben bei der Kauke, oben bei der Kauke.
Nö, David, geh her.
Achtung jetzt.
Next level stream sniping.
Max, komm mal hoch, komm hoch, bitte.
Sonst wirst du da komplett alleine.
Rechts ist auch noch einer.
Ach, der Staubsauger.
Nein.
Max, nix.
Max, lass noch ein bisschen links rumgehen an die Kaukstation.
Oh, links ist auch noch einer hier.
Ich hab grad einen links auf dem Weg gesehen.
Einer tot.
Der ist rechts bei der Kaukstation, rechts von dem Monument.
Ich seh's oben.
Er hängt oben an dem Monument.
Beide haben low.
Cluster, Cluster.
Rechts auch einer.
Zwei tot.
Da oben, die haben beide U-Low.
Ist hier mal?
Vor mir, vor mir, vor mir, anderes Team.
Ich retz dich.
Fuck, fuck, wo? Wo?
Okay, ich retz dich, ich retz dich.
Pass mal auf vor uns.
Anderes Team hier, ganz close.
Hier.
Ich hab dich geschildert.
Hier, ich seh'n sie, links, links, links, links waren sie.
An gelb, an gelb waren die.
Von links könnte ein Team hochpushen, ne?
Ja.
I guess, der rennt mit dem Haus.
Ich hau'n, ich hau'n ein bisschen Schneerstreck drauf.
Ich guck mal in die andere Richtung, dass da nichts hochkommt.
Ich seh' den.
Nice.
Ich kann nicht hin, aber.
Ich push mit vor.
Ja, von mir.
Aber, ob das alle waren?
Egal, ich bin reich, aus irgendeinem Grund spür ich grad planen.
Ich hab' noch ne Munibox hier.
Ich kaufe jetzt einfach mal ne Drohne in den Haus, kommt direkt raus.
Ich will auch Drohne.
Ja, können wir, wir haben genug, wir haben genug.
Ich weiß, wir werden gepusht gleich.
Richtig fies.
Ohne uns selbst wiederbeleben.
Ja, es war ein Self-Revive.
Brauchst du eine raus?
Machen wir, drück mal.
Drück mal eine.
Soll ich eine, ich kann eine rausfahren, wenn ihr wollt.
Ja, mach mal, eine auf jeden Fall.
Ja, links, links, auf dem Weg, auf dem Weg.
Egal, einer da alleine, den können wir schnell holen.
Und dahinter, nee, dahinter kommt sein Trupp.
Egal, bei blau unten, hier müsste sein.
Hier unten rennt er.
Dahinter kommt sein Trupp, ne, nicht vergessen.
Ja, egal.
Der sniped da oder so.
Der ist schlau.
Der war direkt da.
Der ist bei der Einkaufsstation.
Dahinten kommt, aber die werden jetzt auch gepusht, die bei der Kaufe.
Hier auf der Brücke ist einer, da.
Eigentlich ist der Sniper dafür.
Da war eben einer.
Sollen wir den Highground oben aufgeben?
Ich mach's.
Da unten jetzt einen, komm.
Ich glaub, da ist gerade noch mit dem Fallschirm einer runtergelopft.
Nee, kein Hitmarker.
Die sind irgendwie weg oder so.
Im Haus würd ich jetzt noch was recht.
Sollen wir wieder hochgehen?
Geht ihr zurück?
Habt ihr alle Drohne, wir können Orbi halt holen, ne?
Ja, ich hab ohne gerade Ready.
Ich hab keine Ready.
Also ich hab eine, ich hab eine.
Ist nicht Orbi Dreierdrohne oder Vierer?
Dreier, Dreier.
Was, Vierer?
Ach du Scheiße.
Beim Zweier weiß ich's ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber beim Vierer sind's vier.
Wir fehlen auf 400.
Ich hab so gut wie keinen Gegner gehitted, dieses Runde.
Hier 400.
Jaja, ich bin gleich da, ich bin gleich da.
Du hast schon ne Drohne, oder?
Ich hab ne Drohne, ja.
Dann kauf ich noch nen Cluster.
Sollen wir Drohne zünden?
Sollen wir alle mal so nen Orbi machen?
Lass noch nicht, oder?
Doch, close.
Ich hab schon gezündet, ich hab grad schon gezündet.
Der kommt.
Meiner, meiner, ich will auch was killen.
Er hat schon, er hat schon Ahnung.
Er hat überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Okay, wo sind denn die nächsten?
Von rechts pusht da einer.
Warum sind da vier Leute da unten?
Wir müssen von links, von links müssen Vierer Squad.
Die kommen jetzt, die laufen jetzt los.
Sind das Teammates?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, die waren alle in einem Haus gerade.
Ja, die pushten jetzt.
Die gehen aber unten über...
Hm...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Die werden jetzt so gefickt, ja.
Oh.
Donn mal einen, donn mal einen.
Die gehen rechts rum.
Drauf.
Down.
Andere hinterm Felsen.
Unten hat noch einer einen geholt, nicht vergessen.
Hier unten ist einer.
Eine Shitbreak.
Der ist da oben.
Hier hinten hinterm...
Hier hinten hinterm Baum, hinterm Baum.
Aber einer ist hier noch rechts neben euch, ne?
Also an der roten Markierung ist einer am Baum hier, da bei gelb.
Ja, ja, genau.
Der hat Shitbreak, Shitbreak hinterm Baum.
Hier, lila markiert hinterm Baum, ein HP.
Der hat sich selber getötet, null.
Hinten läuft noch einer.
Im Haus unten läuft noch einer.
Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten.
Okay, okay, Achtung Leute.
Im Haus hier drin.
Im Haus hier drin, einer HP.
Also entweder pushen wir die jetzt im Haus unten, wo wir wissen, wo wir sind, oder wir gehen.
Ich würde Highground halten, ich würde Highground halten.
Der Highground halten würde ich auch sagen.
Da wird einer wieder gekauft, da hinten.
Sonst schlägt euch mal die Ammo-Bots hier hin.
Hier.
Da oben kommt er.
Ander ist noch weiter links.
Wo hat er, Alter?
Die sich gehagelt.
Da kommt, Leute, da kommt der nächste.
Hinten, Hinten, Hinten, Hinten.
Ppega Aim.
Der fällt einfach.
Kommt, kommt, kommt.
Direkt hier.
Da mach er irgendwo.
Da hinten, hinten.
Alle Richtung gucken.
Team wipe.
Sechs Teams, sechzehn Leute.
Da kommt noch einer.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen.
Was ist hier gerade los?
Das ist gerade Capture the Hill, Alter.
Das ist gerade die beste Runde immer, Alter.
Links rum, 360 Grad.
Das ist halt echt der Hill.
Tarent Hill.
Orbi hat ja auch scheiße offensichtlich auf Geist, gell?
Können wir irgendwas looten, wo wir Geld kriegen?
Ich hab hier gerade Geld eingesammelt von dem einen.
Ich hab hier gerade Geld eingesammelt von dem anderen.
Hat der hier noch liegen?
Liegt da noch Money?
Hier mal kurz die...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich zum Cash runter kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würd's fast nicht warten.
Doch, ich probier's jetzt.
Komm, du musst jetzt hier raus, Achtung.
Hat der kaum noch was.
Oha, der hat richtig krass hier.
Ah.
Oh, oh, oh.
Da rennt einer, oben fehlt's.
Mhm.
Lul hat den nur Money, so sieht's aus.
Ich hab 300, ich bin rich.
Ich seh niemand.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo der geschossen hat eben.
Von dem Stein, Moritz, grüner Stein.
Soll ich schießen?
Ich hol meine Sniper wieder.
Okay.
Hier im Haus ist auch noch einer, gelb, gelbes Haus.
Der pusht jetzt vor.
Der pusht jetzt vor. Der pusht vor.
Ich seh den, hier in dem Stein.
Ja.
Ich aim ihn mal ab, aber...
Der ist scharf auf mich, der Typ.
Äh...
Ja, der ist immer noch da.
Und die Blades sind im Haus drin noch.
Wie viele sind denn noch übrig?
Noch sechs Gegner, sechs Gegner.
Wir haben grad bisschen Tunnel auf die, gell?
Wir haben Tunnel auf die.
Wow, what the...
Oder, ja, nee, ich lass mich...
Aber wir müssen gucken, dass wir nicht von rechts oder links kriegen.
Nein, ich hab hier alles geklärt.
Rätst ihr mich noch?
Weil sonst kann ich ihn aufheben.
Fuck.
What the fuck?
MonkaS.
Das haben wir zu lange rumgefuddelt.
Was?
Da unten ist einer.
Janu, komm her, komm her.
Janu, wir müssen...
Ich hab mich jetzt geshitbreakt, wo?
Von links sind so so ein Gegner, oder?
Wo habt ihr euch geholt?
Nein, die rechts oder nicht?
Die sagen nicht.
Ja, die Sniper ist halt...
Ich hab von irgendwas selber schon passiert, nach dem zweiten.
Die kommen jetzt rechts halt, und ich hab die geshitbreakt schon.
Die kommen rechts nicht hoch so schnell.
Die müssen.
Links ist halt alles easy.
Da, da, da.
Wo denn?
Der da.
Also...
Einer down, einer down da.
Der andere ist links davon.
Da sind vier Leute.
Zwei down.
Also...
Es hätte seinen Scham, wenn wir uns von manchen Sachen einig wären, was wir machen.
Ja, keine Ahnung, nur dumm ein bisschen.
Ich weiß nicht, wieso ihr da vorne wart, wenn wir hinten noch gespielt haben.
Ja, weil da immer noch die Sniper saßen.
Ja, aber die haben euch halt offensichtlich geholt.
Ja, offensichtlich mit so einem Doppelshot, also zweimal.
Egal.
Das waren aber nicht die von da unten, das waren nämlich...
Das waren andere, deswegen war das so unkoordiniert.
Die kamen von links oder so.
Probiert.
Fortnite, ich verstehe.
Aber die...
Fortnite, die letzte war halt unkoordiniert.
Ja, ich hätte mich weiter durchkratzen sollen, aber ich dachte, du kommst rüber und holst mich.
Es war mir nicht klar, dass es nicht geht.
Das müssen wir...
Sowas müssen wir klarer, klarer sagen.
Also, sonst ist es so...
Sonst verschenken wir da irgendwie zwanzig Sekunden mit rumgeeiern.
Ja.
Egal, man lernt.
Wir haben aber gewonnen, das war nicht schlecht.
Wir gewinnen immer an Erfahrung, sag ich doch.
Only wins.
Ja.
Wie viel sind wir geworden, dritter, zweiter?
Dritter, dritter, dritter.
Hurts, just a little.
War eh nicht meine Runde.
Ihr fühlt...
80.000 Schaden und dann hört man so...
Scoreboard, 6 kills.
Aua.
Oh, shit.
Das Squad leveled up, genau.
Big brain squad.
Jetzt mal ischen.
So.
Moins Squaddle.
Nee, Squatty, das ist ein I.
Ich hab den L gelesen.
Oh, wow.
What the fuck?
Was war das für ne...
Was war das für ne Landung gerade?
Big brain Landung, Alter.
Die Sniper fliegen total komisch, irgendwie.
Die Sniper-Schüsse von dieser Slug Ammo-Sniper oder was das ist.
Das ist doch Gummigeschuss, oder?
Das sind halt die von der MK2, aber...
Ich mein, hallo?
Warum trifft es den Kopf nicht von dem Dude?
Das war komplett rauf.
Der wird...
Irgendwann 5 Sekunden, oder?
Ach ja, kann sein.
Oh, da ist gerade kein Aufwand und keine Kaufe.
Sieht nicht so attraktiv aus.
Nee, Storch Town.
Na, ein Kopfgeld-Auftrag.
Aber ansonsten...
Vielleicht hier hin, oder?
Bei Lila, aber Lila auch immer Spieler.
Ah ja?
Oder Military tatsächlich noch, zu abwechsen.
Entscheidung vielleicht jetzt.
Raus, raus, raus, raus, raus!
Okay, dann da.
Okay, wohin?
Da, da, viele.
Was?
Storch...
Ja, Storch, Storch, Storch, Storch.
Storch, Storch, Storch, Storch.
Hi, IQ Plays.
Wir verwirren die Gegner.
Da kommt kein Schwein mit.
Doch, doch, doch, okay, okay.
Über uns, über uns, über uns.
Hallo, ich brauch Zeug.
Warum haben wir jetzt 8 Spawn-Teams weggeflogen?
Der hat sich richtig verirrt, kann das sein?
Max, ich hab grad über deinem Kopf deinen Namen nicht gesehen, sonst hab ich dich zu schlagen.
Sauerei.
Sauerei, tut mir leid.
Anzeige ist raus, ja.
Und da fängt die Feuer an, der wäre echt schwierig.
Mein Gott, es gibt hier nur Crap-Waffen gerade.
Oha, ich hab direkt gottes Loot.
Grüne M4 und blaue P90.
Oh.
Ich hab ne K98.
Wir haben Schild geschützt, das wollt ihr eigentlich alle.
Du hast die Runde gewonnen, GG.
Vielleicht schießt das von Servo, muss die steuern.
Grüne P90 hier.
Hey, das ist keine Sentry Gun, das muss die Servo steuern.
Ah, die nehm ich, die hol ich mir.
Die ist halt übelst weit weg, nee, ich loote.
Der Sentry Gun wär halt lecker.
Sentry Gun, den war so ein Fock-Cham.
Ich hab meinen Anteil für 10.000.
Ist ja nirgendswo was drinne.
Ich hab auch meinen Anteil.
Geh mal im Schwimmbad gucken.
Reicht, reicht, reicht, reicht.
Ja, Max, ich hab für dich mitgesammelt.
Ja, schön.
Nächste Aufsage ist ja richtig gut dran hier.
Oh, heilige, lass mal zum...
Ja, unter der Brücke halt, unter der Brücke ist halt einer.
Ich würd sagen, wir bleiben zusammen.
Ja, ich komm wieder zurück.
Ja, sagen wir unter die Brücke oder wie heißt denn das Ding?
Parkdeck.
Frag mich nicht, wie hier Sachen heißen.
Parkdeck heißt es, da wo Autos über einem Parkhaus draufparken.
Parkdeck.
Oberstes Parkdeck.
Parkhaus.
Hier liegt Rüstung.
Ich hab schon Muni dabei.
Munikiste.
Wir können die auch hinwerfen wegen hier.
Ich hab Rucksack, passt viel rein.
Brauche ich auch viel.
Wo war die?
Kann man eigentlich hier...
Nee, das geht natürlich nicht.
Diese Wand ist so schlecht.
Ist das mies.
Okay, das ist schlecht.
Das muss man über die...
Okay, das Game ist teilweise echt.
Team, wohin?
Team, Flughafen.
Ja, aber wir haben die Option safe und drop links.
Oder möglicherweise Action und Gulasch rechts.
Action.
Also Gulasch und Action würde ich da sagen.
Action, Action, immer Action.
Die Ausrüstung ist zwar nicht so geil für Action, aber wer braucht das schon?
Solange du eine Maus angeschlossen hast, ist eigentlich egal, was in der Hand ist.
Das ist Wireless-Maus.
Ja, ist so, Vollgas, reicht.
Hier sieht es auch verdammt ungelootet aus.
Immer bait.
Das lassen die immer alle liegen.
War in der Kiste was gescheit?
Ja.
Oder brauchst du das?
Ne, ne, ne.
Ein halber Drop liegt am Drop.
Liegt an Kaufstation.
Er legt noch Papa auf Lotte.
Ach, wir haben eh den Drop ja dann.
XD, ich weiß noch nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Das hat sich gerade ohne Content gestimmt.
Ich hab euch eigentlich gemutet, aber es hat voll nicht funktioniert.
Nimmt sich jemand mit?
Was?
Achso, die hab ich, wenn mir der Drop, wegen dem Drop.
Ich kauf Drohne, ich hab Drohne gekauft.
Du willst zünden?
Weißt du, den können wir wissen.
Ja.
Ich glaub oben, oder?
Oben oder unten?
Oben unten ist Down.
Hast du den jetzt getötet mit drauf springen?
Sah nämlich gerade so aus.
Oh, da kommt dieses Auto.
Ne, das geht.
Aber guck mal da Flugzeug und Flugzeug daneben.
Achso, nicht alleine rausgehen.
Ja, dann auf geht's.
Attack.
Aber im Flugzeug drin, ne?
Im Flugzeug drin, achtung.
Hier müssen wir FBI machen.
Ich hab den, ich hab den Ausgang, ich hab den Ausgang.
Da kommt noch ein Auto, da kommt noch ein Auto.
Ich seh nicht.
Wo ist der?
Der war hier.
Aber der Drohne sagt, also Herzschlag sagt nichts mehr, dann ist er nicht mehr da, oder?
Wenn Herzschlag sagt, dann...
Ne, aber der war ja auf der Drohne.
Wo ist das Auto hingefahren?
Potenziell wird es gleich ein Tower-Sniper, oder?
Hinten fahrend Auto weg.
Check.
Der war noch, der war da drin.
Wow, ich weiß nicht von wo.
Ich hab, vom Dach, vom Dach, vom Dach.
Alter.
Vom Terminal, von dem kleinen.
Ich hab, ich hab OH.
Alter, wo er da sitzt.
Ich geh in Deckung.
Ich check gar nix, ne?
Ich weiß wo, ich weiß wo.
Ich glaub's net, Alter.
Hier, hier, Lila.
Lila oben.
Headclip-Sniper, ja.
Alter, oben.
Oben drauf, Jungs auf, pass fern.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von wo.
Ja, immer noch da oben.
Ja, aber ich hab den nicht gesehen.
Ja, du siehst den auch nicht.
Ich hab leider keine Sniper, dass ich den einfach wegte.
Warum bin ich jetzt aus dem Gulag rausgekommen?
Ey, hast du nicht gekämpft?
Nee.
Betrug.
Ich bin einfach so rausgekommen.
Ja, okay, ich hab gut.
Ja, okay, der steht neben mir.
Kommt doch einfach mal mit.
Der steht im Flugzeug drin.
Ja, ich hab ihn markiert.
Der steht auf der Nut.
Ja, ich will auch aus dem Gulag einfach so raus.
Hinten, der kommt.
Hier, ganz kurz, Gegner.
Okay, ich muss erst mal runter zu euch.
Ja, ich schau von hier oben gerade.
Oh, Moritz, du darfst nicht sterben.
Alter, eben vor dem Flugzeug da unten.
Ich lass ihn mal am Leben.
Wow, es ist ein Mate bei mir.
Hier unten, ein HP, ein HP hat den.
Eliminiert.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich weiß nicht, wer der andere ist.
Der könnte doch noch im Flugzeug gewesen sein.
Also, Flugzeug bin ich gerade lang gelaufen.
Hab ich nix gesehen.
Wo ist der Mate von denen?
Ich muss erst mal runter zu euch.
Ich hab mal denen hier Geld gestopft, Sorge.
Da waren nur zwei, okay.
Liegt noch Waffen.
Überall liegen da noch Waffen.
Wo ist denn der Mate?
Hier lag doch irgendwo eine MP7, die brauch ich.
Die hab ich gerade geholt.
Da liegt aber noch eine MP5.
Wir hatten noch keinen Drop.
Wir müssen zusammenbleiben.
Du müsst mich auch kaufen.
Ich kann nicht zu wohnen.
Ich hab dich schon 80 mal wiederbelebt.
Dann renn ich schon weg.
Dann renn ich weg.
Komm doch mal mit, drei Mal.
Erst mal ein bisschen hier safe gehen wieder.
Jawollo.
Hier kann man natürlich nicht durch, das ist nicht hoch genug.
Da hinten?
Ich werde drohnen wie ein König.
Wo ist denn dahinten?
Ich glaub, in dem Auftrag.
Die machen Duell auf dem Dach hier.
Die schießen sich gegenseitig ab.
Quickscope only.
Bei Lila ist auf jeden Fall noch ein Gegner.
Hier, bei Lila, Gegner.
Ein Team auf den beiden Dächern verteilt.
Zwei, zwei.
Wir sind ziemlich weit verteilt.
Ja, wir sind.
Hier aufs Dach.
Da liegt auch noch ein Loot.
Ich suche gerade noch.
Wie kommt man da hoch?
Wer hat mich angelasert?
Das passiert manchmal random.
Kein Schimmer.
Janow, weißt du, wie man da hoch kommt?
Wo denn?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo du hinkommst.
Hier, so.
Ich denke immer, das geht nicht, aber natürlich geht das.
Das sind die, das sind die.
Das erfordert aber schon die richtigen.
Leute, kommt doch mal zusammen alle und dann...
Wie ist das, habt ihr da hingeknüpft?
Ja, da liegt noch mein Loot.
Hier rum, einfach hier an der Seite.
Unten?
Nee, oben, oben, oben, oben, einfach hier.
Ja, okay.
Ich bin auch runtergefallen.
Lass mal anders rumgehen.
Ich bin auch runtergefallen, jetzt hab ich Zeit.
Okay.
Vielleicht gehen wir einfach hoch aufs Partyset.
Das steht hier oben.
Kommt ihr?
Wir haben noch 32 Zeit, wir machen die jetzt platt.
So.
Der spielt obsidianen Grau.
Ja, die hab ich auch behalten.
Geht los!
Oh mein Gott, sind da viele!
Was?
Okay, okay.
Ich hab einer B.
Ich aim ab, ich aim ab.
Oben.
Okay, der ist armor-prank, einer armor-prank.
Nein, nein, nein, einer HP.
Hinter mir.
Ich hab einen oben.
Einer ist down oben.
Boah, ich hab einer P.
Ich hab die Posse hier gar nicht.
Noch einer down.
Ich bin komplett safe.
Nee, der oben, hier, close bei mir.
Ich hab keine Muni mehr, ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Ich kann hier nicht liegen.
Ich bin fast down.
Oh mein Gott, letzter Schuss.
Wie viel haben wir da gerade gekillt?
Da sind noch mehr, oder?
Da sind noch mehr.
Wir haben da gerade irgendwie, klar, 5 Leute gekillt.
Dann kommen noch mehr.
Lass hier einfach gehen.
Lass einfach abbauen.
Nee!
Komm mit, komm mit, komm mit.
Fuck, hier ist ja gar nichts.
Lass außen rum vorbei, lass außen rum vorbei.
Ja, macht euch vom Acker.
Ihr habt so viel Geld, ihr könnt uns fast holen.
Geht einfach weg.
Da unten, hier oben.
Ich hab keine Platten mehr und sowas.
Seid ihr schon dead?
Die sind beide weg.
Leg mal bitte ein Ding schon, leg mal ein Geld.
Nice.
Ich würde da aber nicht reingehen.
Irgendwo klosst du noch, Kicker.
Das ist da drin echt gefährlich, ne?
Wir können ja mit reingehen jetzt.
Mit unseren mächtigen Pistols.
Da hinten hat es auch noch einen Tropf.
Ist hier irgendwas?
Wir wissen es nicht, da waren ganz viele und dann nö.
Nee, ich meine meine Waffen.
Lass reingehen halt, keine Ahnung.
Lass es als Team beenden oder gewinnen.
Hä, wir können auch einfach weg.
Der kommt nochmal ins Tropf, aber er ist in Ewigkeiten.
Wir können auch mit dem Auto hinfahren.
Ich sehe hier verschiedene, redet mit uns.
Nee, nee, nee.
Redet mit uns.
Da gibt es nicht viel zu reden.
Der ist hier vor mir, da bei Lila drin.
Kommt mächtige Pistol Action.
Und von da oben, Mann.
Wo?
Jetzt komm doch mal raus.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie ich da herkomme.
Ist jetzt Team halb?
Nein, noch einer.
Links, links, links.
Oh nein.
Da drin.
Einer da.
Ich höre hier was laufen bei mir.
Könnte es auch du gewesen sein, weiß nicht.
Bei mir, bei mir, bei mir.
Oh shit.
Alle da.
Kannst du alle kaufen.
Ja, ja, ja, hast du Kram, ey.
Puh.
Mann.
So, wo kann ich kaufen?
Einen auf den, ich könnte alle kaufen, Alter.
Tschüss.
Das war wieder der gleiche, der mich umgebracht hat.
Ich hasse Italiener.
Ich wünsche kein Kram, gell.
Mal gucken, wie viel ich rauskomme.
1013.
Oh Chat, übelst anstrengende.
Hypermonka S.
Ist jetzt eigentlich die Lautstärke okay?
Game-Lautstärke, TS-Lautstärke und alles.
Übrigens für die, danke für die Subs, Freunde.
Ich hab irgendwas übersehen.
Ich glaub, es war sogar noch im letzten Stream.
Weil ich ein wenig auf Spiel konzentriert war.
Ich seh's grad.
Hugo V. hat subscribt, aber es ist schon 4 Stunden her.
Sorry, falls ich's nicht gesehen hab.
Der Stream laggt.
Ich glaub, das liegt an, ich glaub, das liegt an Warzone.
Ich glaub, Warzone ruckelt ab und zu.
Oder laggt wirklich, so mit Aussetzern.
Ah.
Nö, nö, eigentlich.
FPS ist noch, ja, das liegt an Warzone.
Warzone ruckelt manchmal.
Das ist wirklich, das ist Warzone, das ruckelt manchmal.
Ich kann auch mal ausmachen.
Und wir können dann gleich mit NVIDIA-Encoder.
Mit NVIDIA-Encoder.
Primen.
Mach ich nach der Runde.
Dann mach ich noch mal kurz aus und wieder an mit dem, mit,
dann mach ich Hardware-Encoder.
Mal gucken, wie's funktioniert.
Ja, ich probier's danach.
Hast du auch an oder CPU?
Ja, hab ich auch an.
Ich hab NVEC-Codec.
Max, bist du zu stressig genug?
Ja.
Ich fühl mich jetzt wie 48.
Morgens, hau die Kiste.
Ja, bin schon dabei.
Ja, ja.
Rechts hinter, also auf der anderen Seite, da wo ich gestorben bin,
hinter der Bande hier rechts irgendwo, hinter den Sitzen.
Ich hab ein Problem.
Ich hab ein Problem, das heißt, ich bin tot.
Aus dem Sniper-Tower.
Sniper-Tower sag ich, aus dem Airport-Tower.
Äh, Achtung Max.
Aus dem Tower, ne?
Ich geh rein, ich geh rein, ich geh rein.
Soll ich nicht ohne Tower?
Wir wissen, dass die zumindest mal im Tower drin sind.
Aus dem Tower-Team drin.
Hier drin könnt ihr Loot aussuchen.
Ich hab einen gedauert im Tower.
Alles?
Wo ist denn der Top-Tier?
Ich hab nur einen gedauert im Tower.
Lass ich überhaupt da hochkommen.
Haben wir hier irgendwie noch eine SMG oder irgendwas?
Oder Oden, Alter.
Ja, wo?
Da ist das Rucksack, gell?
Sniper-Money.
Hier, hier musst du die legen, hier bei mir.
Hier, da.
Ah, so, sehr gut.
Sieben, Hammer.
Sollen wir rechtsrum aus dem Airport raus, Richtung hier?
Hast du jetzt die MP7 genommen gerade?
Ja, nimm die hier.
Das ist übelst kaputt, das Gelute.
Hier, da, hier ist sie doch.
Ich hab nur dann keine Waffe, aber egal.
Ah, du hast die, ich wollt grad sagen, wo ist sie hin?
Nur noch die Oben.
Hier, hier liegt noch eine M.
Max, du nimmst die nicht.
Ich hab die alles.
Das backt übelst rum gerade.
Das ist eine HDR.
Bei mir, bei mir.
Okay.
Rot, Teamwipe.
Wir linksrum aus dem Airport gehen, loll.
Das ist meine Graube.
Der hatte meine Graube.
So, Jungs, jetzt erstmal alle in Ruhe in eine Richtung.
Ich würde nach Purple gehen.
Ja, wir gehen.
Es bringt nichts, wenn wir den im Turm pushen, das muss ja nicht sein.
Das bringt vor allem nichts, wenn wir nach rechts rum gehen, weil da ist viel zu viel.
Dass wir wirklich nach links rum gehen.
Haben wir noch ein paar Platten?
Wenn nicht, wir können doch an der Kaufi vorbei.
Ja, bei Purple hat es auch Kaufi.
Jawoll, dann machen wir das.
Das Einzige, was jetzt passieren kann, ist, dass er jetzt Deutschland pusht.
Das haben wir schon geklärt vor vier Jahren.
Und alles, was drunter kommt.
Na, Yves, sowas zu denken.
Äh, okay.
So, jetzt, Leute, vierter Win, easy.
Ich bin aber doch auch Win.
Wer hat auf mich geschossen?
Wo denn?
Hier, vor da, die Schweine.
Oh Gott.
Oha, oha, hallo, ich schieße zurück.
Alter, wo sind die denn?
Die schießen hinten wie irre auf mich.
Ich schieße zurück.
Ihr könnt gehen, ich schieße.
Er chat.
Bei mir braucht es zum Rendern, bis ich in dem Haus bin.
Der Chat macht sich über Kaufi lustig.
Was sagt er dazu?
Hey, das habe ich immer gesagt.
Das Beste.
Ich bin gelasert, wer hat gelasert?
Hinter uns, hinter uns.
Down, down.
Aber der lebt noch, der lebt noch.
Nein, und jetzt wieder von denen.
Nein, nein, nein, der andere Rätsel jetzt.
Auch jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, Team Vibe, jetzt Team Vibe.
LulHD macht es klar hier.
Wo ist der Sky Chat?
Wir haben hier eine nicht allzu tolle Pose, oder?
Wenn die Hops gehen, kriegen wir richtig Asche, wir kriegen richtig Asche, wenn die Hops gehen.
6.000.
Wo genau waren die denn jetzt?
Wir sind in dem Flugzeugtower drin, drei Köpfe, die haben richtig Spaß da oben und da unten.
Einer von denen ist jetzt tot, aber das ignorieren wir jetzt einfach.
Also der ist gedownt.
Ich spiele solche Schmutzwaffen.
Wir haben jetzt kurz Ruhe, lasst damit durch den Tunnel hochgehen.
Oder außen rum.
Lasst durch den Tunnel halt.
Was ist das denn mit Tracer?
Ja, das spiele ich auch so.
Ey, aber durch den Tunnel wird es echt knapp gelb von der Zeit her.
Was? 51 Sekunden muss ich halt jetzt los.
Und dann nach links halt, ne?
Und dann hier, ach so.
Ja, ja, das meine ich doch, das gleiche.
Willst du mich?
Vor links, vor links, vor links.
Der ist direkt hier dahinter.
Der, ne, ne, ne, der ist direkt hier dahinter.
Einer tot.
Ist Teammate?
Ok, ich hole dich, ich hole dich, ich hole dich.
Er liegt eben nirgendwo, kann man sagen.
Ich muss den kurz teamwecken.
Mach ruhig, ich hab ihn schon gut.
Was ist das denn für ein Mensch?
Wir müssen noch zum Drop, gell?
Ich hab eigentlich ganz gute Equipment, das kann ich mir kleben.
Ich hab alles, ich hab alles.
Ich brauch Geist.
Geist hab ich nicht, das...
Geist hab ich.
Eh dahin, also dem ist es egal.
Oder hab ich Geist?
Nee.
Ich hab auch kein Geist.
Ich hab gelootet vor den Gegnern, ich hab gar keine Perks.
Ich hab auch kein Geist, merk ich grad.
Sollen wir da echt hin zum Drop?
Da drin ist noch Muni, aber ich brauch doch keine Muni.
Oh, hat die Fight mega hart da hinten.
Der Drop ist doch, der Drop ist übel, du drin für uns.
Ja, am Auto, am Auto, da gehen wir gleich drauf.
Ich hab einen.
Nee, hab ihn nicht, der muss da liegen.
Wo?
Hier, hier, hier, der ist genommen.
Der ist am Auto.
Am Auto muss genommen werden.
Rechts, rechts, rechts.
An der Tür war er.
Der hat's reingeschafft, der hat's reingeschafft.
Achtung, vom Sniper Turm, vom Sniper Turm.
Hier Leute, wir müssen da weg.
Das sind fünf Leute auf dem Sniper Turm.
Und von unten, unten sind auch noch welche gewesen.
Und von unten sind auch noch welche gewesen.
Aua, aua, ich helf euch.
Boah.
Keiner Down.
Mokka ist...
Nee.
Die fliegen runter, die Sniper.
Die kommen, die Sniper, gell?
Die haben eine sehr gute Zone.
Wir müssen gucken, die können jetzt von...
Ey, der Zaun, der nervt ja mal brutal, der kann einfach nichts.
Äh.
Ich hab eine witzige Idee, die könnte...
An dem Haus, an Gelb irgendwo.
Alter.
Was ist mit den Gegnern grad los?
Da unten im Haus, die haben Sniper und RPG, ich hasse die.
Bist du safe?
Ja, ich bin safe, aber schnell.
Die auf so einem Highground haben, das kann ein Tod-Highground sein, glaub ich.
Die sind ja mal so...
Wir sollten uns ein bisschen repositionieren, dass sie nicht mal wissen, genau wo wir sind.
Ja, mach ich.
Ich werde eins mit der Steinwand.
Leute, ich bin in der Leitplanke.
Die sehen uns jetzt aber schön hier rennen.
Ja, ich hab das wegen, ob ich ja kalt bin, die sehen uns nicht.
Aber wir sind alle...
Ja.
Das schaltet auch die Augen aus.
Ja, aber die sind ja dumm wie Holz, sie spielen Sniper mit RPG.
Das könnte eine sehr gute Pose sein hier.
Ist doch ein geiles, das hier.
Aber ich komm nicht hoch zu euch.
Wieso denn nicht?
Die ist so ein bisschen gut, nicht so richtig.
Es gefällt mir...
Es gefällt mir nicht hier oben drauf, ey.
Ja, mir auch nicht, aber...
Hier rechts rum, zu grün, oder?
Wo denn?
Wie soll man da hochkommen, hä?
Boah, hier, jetzt hier, ganz noch weiter hin.
Wie würde ich mich wohlfühlen, wenn ich Sniper hätte?
Hier, an Gelb. An Gelb auf dem Dach.
Oh mein Gott.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Der stirbt.
Hinterm Stein.
An Gelb.
An Gelb hinterm Baum, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den seht.
Da rettet einer hinten.
Da ist einer hinten gerannt.
Der hinten unten ist down.
Der hinten ist down.
Was ist mit dem an Gelb? Wisst ihr, wo der hin ist?
Nee, das ist dahinter.
Ich kann nichts markieren wegen der Marke.
Lass noch ein bisschen rumsneaken.
Ah, die beballern sich hier gerade.
Ja, ist okay.
So, ich komm jetzt mit runter.
Schildbreak.
Schildbreak, ein HP.
Warum schießt du nicht, Budi?
Hab ich doch, aber in den Baum.
Der hat einen HP.
Die schießen zurück und jetzt wissen sie, dass wir kaputt sind.
Die schießen zurück und jetzt wissen sie, dass wir kommen.
Wir sind zurück, Sauerei, Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Links, links, zwei.
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Einer Schildbreak.
Willst du den weifeln? Oh nein, den.
Einer down von denen.
Noch einer Schildbreak.
Drei down.
Ich hab den mit C4.
Das ist halt gegen zwei, gegen zwei, gegen zwei.
Noch einer down.
Gegen einen.
Der eine müsste, der eine müsste bei mir hier irgendwo sein.
Der kann hier in dem Haus campen.
Ich glaub, der ist hier in dem Haus, ja.
Ja, glaub ich auch.
Oben.
Ich geh da jetzt ran.
Unten, unten, unten, unten ist er.
Dahinter, dahinter.
Da rechts.
Jawoll.
Bam.
So muss das sein.
Vierter Win.
So geht's ab.
Chet ist in Ekstase, so wie es aussieht.
Eats, GG.
Am besten finde ich ja die Kombination aus Jeets.
Nein, das heißt Jeets.
Also in MMOs hieß das mal Kratz früher.
Aber Jeets ist...
Ich bin jetzt schon kurz raus auf jeden.
Max wartet schon auf einen Anruf, der andere.
Naja.
Der eine ist raus, wird direkt ausgewächst.
Ist alles eine Frage der Organisation.
Ja, echt so.
Alles nur Wingroof.
Bist du nicht online?
Oh, ja.
Wer, du hast es nicht vergessen.
Moritz, aktualisieren.
Win-Rate.
Win-Win-Counter.
Okay, ist gut.
Ich habe ihn getötet und mein erster trifft ihn links.
Hallo.
Hi.
Jiri wechselt.
Der wird ausgewechselt.
Warum?
Der macht eine Pause.
Nein, der muss ausgewechselt werden.
Der macht keine Pause.
Der hat echt was Schlimmes gemacht.
Der hat mich zu schwer revifed.
Der ohne Witz hat every night never raves echt nie.
Unfriend, unfollow.
Unfriend.
Du kannst jetzt abgucken, mit wem du so in der Lobby warst.
Also welche Gegner.
Chat, mal eine Frage.
Soll ich den Stream neu steuern mit nveng?
Oder ist das, dass es ruckelt ab und zu nicht so schlimm?
Weil ich glaube, das liegt gar nicht an mir.
Ich glaube, das liegt schlicht und ergreifend an Warzone.
Weil bei mir ruckelt Warzone zwischendurch auch einfach mal random.
Ohne irgendwie tieferen Sinn.
Ich weiß nicht, ob nveng da was bringt.
Also wenn es so schlimm ist, dass man es nicht gucken kann, dann starte ich neu.
Aber ansonsten würde ich laufen lassen.
Geht schon.
Liegt am Game.
Liegt am Game, ja, glaub ich auch.
Ich hab das sogar, ich guck hier ab und zu mal Huskas oder Husky, ne Huskas.
Der hat das auch ab und zu.
Das scheint an Warzone zu liegen.
Irgendwo muss man sich ja die Pro-Tipps holen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, Chat, ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt ja so, glaub ich hab jetzt so um die 85, 90 Games.
Seit der Capture Card ist das weg.
Ja, ja, klar, das war es anders.
Wenn ich über die Elgato aufnehmen würde vom anderen Rechner, glaube ich auch, dass es gehen würde.
Das dürfte jetzt ungefähr das 85. Game gewesen sein, Warzone oder so.
Und ich muss sagen, nachdem ich es am Anfang echt krass verkemmt und, und, wie soll ich sagen,
random fun, muss ich sagen, mittlerweile macht es echt Spaß.
Warzone hat den Modern Warfare Multiplayer einfach total gerettet.
Der Multiplayer ist schon nach wie vor, aber Warzone hat es insofern gerettet,
dass die Leute das Spiel spielen. Es wäre ohne Warzone wäre das Spiel halt dead.
Hast du ja davor gesehen Twitch?
Twitch, 2500 Leute Modern Warfare, seit Warzone raus ist es irgendwie 80.000 oder so.
Es hat ein paar komische Sachen, genau, zum Beispiel RPGs sind merkwürdig.
Die technische Seite von dem Spiel ist wirklich grottenschlecht, so wir Gebäude nicht laden und sowas.
Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, das ist aus einem Grund so erfolgreich,
weil es der quasi casualigste und gleichzeitig aber irgendwie noch ein bisschen skilllastigste Battle Royale,
also die niedrigste Einstiegshürde, aber doch ganz gut noch sich verbessern war, Battle Royale Modus ist.
PUBG ist übel schwierig reinzukommen, Fortnite mit dem ganzen Rumme-Gebaue,
es gab mal Realm Royale, dieses mit dem Chicken, das haben sie aber, Hi-Rez, Keg-W, voll verkackt.
Das haben die ganz gut hingekriegt.
Das haben die ganz gut hingekriegt. Und ich glaube, die wurden selbst ein bisschen überrascht von dem Erfolg von Warzone.
Ich glaube, die haben das sich schon erhofft, ja, aber ich glaube, sie wurden überrascht selbst ein bisschen von dem Erfolg letztendlich.
Sie haben quasi den Erfolg, den sich die Firestorm-Battlefield-Leute erhofft haben irgendwo.
Genau, genau, das Wiederkaufen, dass man permanent quasi solange einer lebt, nicht wirklich raus ist, ist auch gut.
Und meistens dauert es ja gar nicht so lange, bis man bis respawned wird.
Entweder gewinnt man den Gulag oder wenn die eigenen Leute noch gut in der Runde sind, das habt ihr ja gesehen.
Ich meine, ich war in der eine Runde dreimal tot oder so.
Ja.
Ja gut, die Performance ist Crap, ja.
So, ich mache jetzt mal TS wieder an.
Wo war man runter?
Wo war man runter? Superstore, wie immer.
Ach nee, nee, nee, nee, lass ruhig.
Ich habe mich eigentlich versprochen, da habe ich mir gedacht, ich passe das ganz gut.
Die schlimmste Multiplayer, okay, die zweitschlimmste Multiplayer.
Ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen, Piccadilly übertrifft echt nichts.
Also Piccadilly ist keine Map.
Der Praktikant, Alter.
Chat ist eigentlich mit dem ins Mikrofon atmen jetzt besser.
Ich habe das Noisegate eingeschaltet, also sprich, wenn ich einfach nur atme, dann hört man das nicht.
Oh, Killhouse, ja.
Killhouse, das sieht so aus wie diese 2&2 Map ein bisschen.
Ja, das haben sie hier auch Remaked, aber habe ich noch nie gespielt.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Achtung, Achtung.
Oh, oh, oh, bei mir sind total viele, what the fuck.
Monka, Monka.
Okay, ich habe echt ein Problem, hier ist nichts.
Hier bei mir ist noch einer drin.
Monka, Hilfe.
Irgendwo hier kommt einer.
Irgendwo hier hinten ist einer.
Ich brauche eine Waffe, Alter.
Hat er was?
Ja, ja, ich komme, ich komme, ich komme.
Ist das auf der Seite oder auf der anderen?
Shit, Shit, Shit, Shit.
Der pusht mich gleich, der pusht mich gleich.
In so einem seitlichen Garage.
Super.
Kack.
Monka S.
Was ein Start.
Ich bin immer noch mit im Fight.
Ja, ja, du machst das, du machst das, easy win.
Ich haue ab.
Oh Mann, das ist so peinlich.
Didi, hast du den Leut schon verloren?
Ja.
Nee, er ist nicht so gut.
Nee, ich dachte nur, ey, was machst du eigentlich?
War, ich war innerhalb von drei Sekunden im Boot.
Ich habe einen geholt und wurde geholt.
Nein.
What?
What the fuck?
What the hell?
Wie hat er das überlebt?
Ich habe vor dem angefangen zu schießen, war voll auf dem drauf.
Aber dann easy, ja.
Ich bin übrigens sinnlos gestorben, ich weiß nicht warum.
Du bist auch zur Strafe schon einmal ohne Kampfforbe rausgekommen.
Och nee, du bist doch nicht weg, du Säcke.
Unter dir, ha?
Kann ich, ey?
Mit Hass.
Was hältst du von den neuen Aktivitäten von Anonymous?
Was machen die denn?
Ich habe nichts mitgekriegt.
Sind die bei, machen die in den USA irgendwie Zeug?
Oder was? Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe das nicht mitgekriegt.
Du hättest einfach mich holen können, ich hätte dir meine Waffel getroffen und das reinrennen können.
Ja warte mal, wie viel ist die Waffe, wenn du ausgenäht bist?
Ja, ist auch nicht schlimm.
Was ist mit Treppen, was ist der erste Schritt mit Treppen?
Nee, kommt nicht in Frage.
Wenn du sagst, der ist close.
Die sind nicht gekommen, weil ich hier in der Wand war.
Ja, man weiß es ja nicht. Mach die weg, mach die weg.
Das kann schon mal passieren, ich meine, das war übelst random, wir haben auch relativ viel gekillt, aber...
Ich komme schon wieder.
Ey, man, was ist denn das? Ich dachte, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es laggt wie Sau.
Ja, ab und zu stand ich gerade.
Nee, ich sehe es bei dir in der Kill-Camp gerade oder in der Spectator-Camp.
Wo ich da ab und zu mal rumstehe, ne?
Ja.
Jetzt lags auch bei uns, der Server.
Das hat sich nichts verdient.
Ich habe mich gesehen hier.
Nein!
Der Server lags heftig.
Kein Packet-Loss oder so.
Bei mir eigentlich, alles gut.
Ich habe gelesen, dass die ganzen Europe-Server nach Russland, also in Russland stehen oder in Asien.
Von denen für das Spiel.
Wo landest du eigentlich?
Ja, ich wollte bei meinem Loot landen.
Du hattest doch nichts.
Ich hatte doch eine Waffe und eine Sniper.
Ich hatte alles.
Und keine Platten.
Alles wird gut.
Solange du wild bist.
Bleib wild.
Ich kann fast schon einen retten.
Jo.
Mach den mal in die Richtung ein.
Bist du schon hier?
Gut, dass ich ihn leider aufhauen kann.
Eine Treppe.
Hi.
Vielleicht doch für beide.
Eine Box oder zwei.
Aber Moritz, kommst du denn zu uns, Max?
Ja, ja.
Ach Leute, ihr dürft euch übrigens nicht verwirren lassen.
Der heißt auch Max.
Deswegen hört sich das jetzt zu merkwürdig.
Ich bin tot, er meint nicht mich.
Und es ist noch eine Kiste.
Ich hoffe einfach mal.
Moritz ist auf dem Parkdeck vom Airport.
Ah ja.
Oh.
Der ist plötzlich abgehoben.
Der will rein.
Da haben welche gerannt.
Moin, die sind genau oben.
Komm mit, komm rauf.
Da sind drei Stück.
Komm rauf.
Okay, ich komm nicht zu dir, ich vergiss es.
Noch eine arme Box.
Hey Max.
Renax, bist du bei Unity Media?
Jo.
Wenn der eine kommt reicht es doch, oder?
Kommt auch an, wie viel Geld der hatte.
Ich hatte null.
Ja okay, dann hol Max, hol Max, hol Max.
Okay.
Ready.
Ja.
Ich komm mit, ich komm mit, ich komm mit.
Ha.
Kommt zu euch.
Was für ein Crap.
Ja.
Ist richtig, ja.
Also, bei mir geht es, bei mir geht es.
Es scheint wirklich was zwischen dir und dem Server oder bei dir auf der Kiste zu sein.
Bei mir ist es aber auch, dass es so leckt.
Ja, weil ich ja auch wirklich komplett schampel.
Ich kann halt nichts machen.
Moritz, ich geb dir Geld, hol Marcelli.
Wo ist der Geld?
Geld?
Geld ist da.
Ach, da ist ja ein Drop.
Fuck.
Nee, machen wir noch nicht, wir brauchen die noch nicht.
Doch, brauchen wir, ich hab die keine.
Hast du gelegt? Okay.
Vielleicht da.
So wichtig ist die dann auch nicht.
Pssst.
Ich drop mal meine 5 Platten hier und hol mal ein neuer.
Ja, mach das, dann kannst du hier auch die noch nehmen.
Mhm.
Von wo ballerts?
Bin ich.
Ah, irgendwo auf dem Airfield glaub ich, nix bei uns.
Also ich hab fast voll Armor, kann sich jemand anderes nehmen?
Wieso?
Armor boxt schon wieder ran.
Nee, ich war hier die markierten Platten.
Ach so, ja.
Jetzt, da braucht sie dir gar nicht mehr, dann kann ich die Armor boxt nehmen und die 5 Platten machen.
Ah, eine nehm ich noch.
Ist hier oben nicht ne Refill?
Doch, doch, doch.
Ach, unten ist die.
Ist das auch random, wo die spawnen?
Immer gleich.
Du bist grad noch alleine, Max.
Immer gleich hier.
Okay, komm ich vor.
Geld, Geld.
Ja, Geld.
Reich.
Oh, jetzt lags du aber auch richtig heftig.
Ja, das ist irgendwie deine Verbindung, Moritz.
Meine?
Ja, weil dein Mic grad auch Platz gedeckt hat.
Jetzt gehts aber wieder, oder?
Ja, aber es ist nur so sporadisch.
Noch ganz bisschen.
Ab und zu.
Ah, warte, was war das?
Shotgun oder was?
Ah, shit.
Ich seh nichts.
Das heißt nicht, dass da niemand ist.
Das stimmt, das haben wir ja gelernt heute oft genug.
Ein paar Kills stieg so nüchtern, wie sowas, wäre schon nice.
Ja, meine Bitrate ist bei 5995 und wird als rot angezeigt.
Äh, dann hast du...
Rot angezeigt heißt, du hast Verbindung zu Twitch.
Also du kannst nicht schnell genug uploaden, vielleicht weil dein Provider rumspackt.
Du hast aber auch grad richtig geleckt im TS.
Ja, aber jetzt...
Ja.
Er hat richtig geleckt im TS.
Ist nichts mehr.
Wieder belebt unten an der Graustation.
Was? Ah.
Da, da, irgendwo innen in mir.
Wollen gucken, wo sein Segelkollege runterkommt.
Ist alles nichts mehr.
Okay.
Die hauen ab Richtung Airfield über den Graben.
Dann lassen wir die hoch, oder?
Guck mal, ob der Fallschirm sich in welche Richtung da geht.
Ich seh ihn halt nicht.
Ja, er ist halt weg.
Da schießt so ein Leute...
Auf was denn?
Ist doch grad nix.
Der Chat ist so ruhig, weil das hier Big Brain Highly Focused Gameplay ist.
Die sind alle hier am mitschwitzen.
Max hat grad erst aus.
Ja, was, was?
Wenn du mir Geld gibst, kann ich mir ne Drohne kaufen.
Recht sich aufs Geld gibt immer alles.
Ah.
Hier sind die Pro-Tips heute, Chat, seht ihr?
Land mal was.
Soll ich raus haben, oder warum nicht?
Ja, ich würd schon sagen, oder?
Dahinten ist ein Sniper.
Direkt gegenüber.
Ross ist ein Sniper aus dem Hangar.
Ja, bei Gelb in dem Haus den Gegner.
Jawoll, bei Blau die machen wir direkt.
Lass mal pushen, lass mal pushen.
Ja, ich komm mit.
Max, Achtung, ich bin noch nicht da.
Ich hab Punktestelle.
Der schießt auf mich.
Oben im Fenster, Armor Break.
Armor Break im Fenster oben.
Ich hab drei.
Hol ihn dir.
Ich hab alle vier.
Echt, Pog, nice.
Ich hab zwei davon Gold geschossen, sehr geil.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier alles draus?
Erstmal aufsaugen.
Aha.
Aber kein Geld, ne?
Kein Geld.
Der hat jetzt die Sniper des Snipers.
Hi.
Was war das?
Ja, ich bin hinter dir her und hab links gedreht.
Wer war das denn?
Ich.
Dahinten auf dem Hangar.
Guck mal her.
Boah, boah.
Die Sonne geht richtig ekelig hoch.
Da kommt ein Auto.
Erstmal ein Luftschlag drauf.
Links.
Was? Ist was bei uns, Klaus?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube, er hat mich gerade schießen gehört.
In der Halle, zu rechts.
Die pushen wir jetzt aber nicht, über das Airfield.
Nee, nee, nee, die müssen herkommen.
Die müssen herkommen.
Lass ihn einsteigen.
Als Snipers.
Auto.
Da ist einer in der Zone.
Ja, in der Zone.
Sonst klemmen die uns gleich ab.
Ich hab noch einen Trophy.
Stand von hinten.
Als Fünfter bin.
Diese Ansprüche.
Ja.
Wir brauchen Geld.
War da noch Loot oder was?
Ja, alles so ein bisschen fest drauf.
Hätte ihnen den PK best noch cooler gewesen.
Sollen wir den Dumm-Move hochbringen?
Oder das dann den normalen Weg laufen?
Hier ist alles leer, ja.
Den straighten, oder?
Wegen Zeit wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Du, wir würden den anderen auch schaffen.
Ja gut, ist egal halt.
Ich hab noch eins.
Links rum, rechts rum.
Rechts rum.
Schaut mal auf dem Radar, ob es ein Buggy mit den Hungertypen kommt.
Dass wir die irgendwie noch im Hinterkopf behalten.
Jawoll.
Alle schon geludet.
Wieso ist hier eine Tour noch auf?
Bait, bait, bait.
Buche, boche.
Ich glaube, das darf mit da gehen.
Wollen wir wieder den Sneaky-Dumb-Move machen, oder wie?
Oder was?
Wir sind schon weit.
Ein Auto hinter uns?
Oben auch noch Auto, unten und oben Auto.
Scheiße.
Oben sind drei.
Das sind jetzt drei Autos.
Wir sind, der eine ist ins Haus.
Einer ist links, einer ist links, einer ist links.
Ich push mal ran.
Da ist einer, da ist einer unter dir.
Ich hab noch einen genockt.
Push ran ins Haus.
Links war der letzte, glaube ich.
Oh mein Gott.
Der schläft bei mir.
Ahja, ich sehs.
Der hat aber noch einen genockt.
Im Haus den hab ich gekillt.
Der hat so viele Gegner.
Guck das hier selbst halt nicht.
Wollen wir außen rumflanken, Max?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Ja lass abhauen, lass abhauen.
Wir sind einfach oben.
Oben.
Weggefahren, weggefahren.
Von links.
Von hinten.
Ich sehs.
Lass mal auf die Polizeistation stehen.
Auf der Polizeistation stehen, Leute.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Passt mir auf.
Ich hab einen gesehen, keine Ahnung.
Der hat gewartet bis ich hochkomme.
Der lag da an der Leiter.
Du wirst mich verarschen, Alter.
Kann ich sagen.
Lass mal über links gehen dann.
Vorne ist ja noch einer, ne?
Am blau.
Der kann an das Haus stehen hier.
Da ist ein Kisten drin, aber heißt ja nichts.
Ich geh mit dem MP rein.
Max, die sind schon weiter gelaufen.
Bleibt lieber an der Treppe hängen.
Warte, wo ist er auf der Polizeistation?
Wahrscheinlich 2. Stock ist oder so.
Ich aim rein.
Ja da ist er, da ist er.
Da ist er, da ist er.
Ich hätte ihn sonst nicht entkommen.
Habt ihr ihn oben?
Okay, nice.
Wo sind denn jetzt die anderen?
Da oben, oben, oben.
Weg.
Nice.
Ja, ich loote die.
Da oben.
Okay, ich loote die nicht.
Ich komm mit vor.
Ja, ich seh nix.
Kommt mal in dieses Kackhaus hier rein.
Irgendwo von der Seite hat mich was gehittet.
Moritz, hinter dir sind auch noch welche, ne?
Da kann ich...
Richtung Auftrag.
Oh, oh, oh.
Moritz, hinter dir sind auch noch welche, ne?
Da kann ich...
Richtung Auftrag.
Ich komm jetzt vorgelaufen.
Ach, Quatsch.
Du musst aufpassen, wenn du auf der Straße bist.
Die können direkt hier drauf gucken.
Von hinten die.
Die sind im Auto.
Kann das sein, dass die im Auto waren?
Ja, lass hier hoch, lass hier hoch.
Links rum oder rechts rum?
Links oder rechts?
Oh Gott.
Alter, was ist das hier wieder?
Mittendurch.
Komm jetzt von oben.
Da müssen die jetzt kommen.
Wir müssen einfach nur schnell hoch, dann können wir es schaffen.
Die sind schon links weg.
Die hätten hier schon links sein müssen.
Wie gesagt,
aus der Richtung von Blau
könnten durchaus auch noch gleich Quatsch kommen.
Von hinten, ne?
Also die sind nicht tot gewesen.
Ich seh niemand.
Ohne Pust.
Ich seh keinen rennen.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht sind die beim Auto abgehauen.
Wiedergekauft hier.
Aber die,
die gerade schießen rechts von euch, machen den weg,
der wiedergekauft wurde.
Also der wiedergekauft hat unten in der Kaufstation.
Auf die Feuerwehrstation geht ein Klasserschlag runter.
Das war ein bisschen langsamer.
Oder ganz schnell zu der Schicht.
Ich bin aber nicht so mit ihm.
Gleichzeitig bin ich.
Lone Wolf, Max.
Da vorne kommt eine Runde.
Auf dem
rechts von euch, also geradeaus,
wo ihr grad das Fusslust kommt, das Führerteam von...
Wir können dich kaufen, ne?
Theoretisch.
Rück mal.
Ich mach mal den hier.
Direkt vor uns.
Ein HP.
Von links, von links auch noch.
Achtung.
Ich hab ihn getötet, Max.
Den links oder vorne im Haus?
Hier rein, hier rein.
Oben runter.
Nein, nein.
Achtung, ich hab einen.
Von der Straße, von der Straße.
Ich weiß nicht von wo der war.
Oben, oben, hier.
Hier, Max.
Ich hab ihn.
Okay, ich retz dich jetzt.
Irgendwo unten war noch einer,
auf der anderen Seite von der Straße.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Sah nur so aus.
Der hat einfach nur so...
Ich hab ihn klar zu.
Alles gut, ich hab nie seine Zweifel.
Lass mal hier rechts, der ist immer rechts im Shop.
Ich brauch eine neue Waffe eigentlich.
Hier vorne, auf dem Weg noch in die Zone.
Was für ein Grau, Alter.
23, Alter.
Wie viele leben da noch?
Da hinten einer, die klaut, da oben.
Hier, der spielt keinen Schalldämpfer.
Der spielt keinen Schalldämpfer.
Ja, aber nicht schießen, wir wollen noch anschleichen.
Bei dem Shop, wo die auch eingekauft haben.
Da vorne drinnen.
Zone kommt viel zu schnell, das schaffen wir nicht.
Alter.
Ich muss hier raus, Alter.
Monka ist...
Im Bunker.
Ja, Bunker welche und links welche.
Lass mal hier über den Bunker laufen.
Direkt unter uns, die müssen raus.
Ja.
Da vorne rennen auch welche.
Da ist einer im Propp.
Die kommen gar nicht raus.
Die haben keinen Bock, die sind aber hinter uns noch.
Ich hab vielleicht eine Gasmaske.
Da ist er.
Warum schreit ihr so?
Ich hab ihn, ich hab ihn.
Hast du eine Gasmaske?
Nee, ich hab auch keine.
Sniper, links vom Bunker, links vom Bunker.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal rein.
Ich bin im Krieg.
Der hat gerade gute Hits.
Der war hier am blau.
Kann durchaus sein, dass der hinten durchflankt.
Egal.
Wenn es klappt, dann klappt es nicht.
Sehr gut, danke.
Oben ist er, oben, ich hab einen gesehen.
Ich hab 3, ich hab 2 Kloppen.
Die waren shotgun, Moni.
Hier ist Teddy, Teddy.
Die gehen hier, hier.
Lass mal hier raus.
Lass mal außen auf den Bunker laufen.
Wie gesagt Richtung Nordwesten.
Der war nicht mehr alle da.
Hat einer noch Platten?
Nee, ich hab 2.
Achtung.
Ihr müsst die scouten.
Geht noch rechts hoch.
Dann habt ihr die Beste.
Platten, wo waren die Platten?
Da.
Nice, nice.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich sollte die mit dem Auto überfahren.
Die sind da vor uns.
Passt alle, die sind ziemlich lau.
Ich push mal ein bisschen vor.
Von der Seite, von der Seite kommt noch einer.
Der hat uns geflankt.
Von der Seite.
Richtung Lila.
Hinter dem Baum.
Intense, intense.
Was hat die Klappe mit dem Auto eigentlich?
Wenn ich ihn überfahren soll.
Nice try.
Ich hab den einig gemacht noch.
NT, NT, NT in chat.
NT.
Aieieieiei.
Der hat einfach einen Ungekämpfer.
Der einfach nur in der Zone chillt.
Und dann noch einen mit, bevor er eh spielt.
Hammer Tactics.
So gefällt mir.
Die Runde war trotzdem nice.
Weite, dritte, erste.
Witz.
Also es geht auf.
Squad leveled up.
Morgen ist neue Season.
Ach hab ich eigentlich alles?
Wo steht denn das hier?
Battle Pass?
Du musst auch von der Bühne Richtung kommen.
Wenn du alle Talents das Reich halten willst.
Ach juckt mich nicht.
Juckt mich nicht.
Crossbow.
Pong aus Crossbow Snipes.
Ich hab's gehört ja.
Die gingen sie aber voll durch hier.
Es gibt aber immer die gleichen Klassen im Warmup.
So nach 5 Tagen Spielzeit.
Es gibt in dem Game eh sehr viel so das Gleiche.
Wo man sich da denkt, okay Copy Paste.
Die Häuser einfach.
Aber den Vorteil ist, dass du auf die Häuser kennst.
Also.
Ja man.
4 Stunden 50.
Ohne gebrochenen Warzone Crane.
Hammer.
Du hast mich gesehen.
Da steht er.
Okay.
Wenn er Standard droppt, da gibt es Suchaufträge.
Einen.
Oder? Wo wollen wir?
Ich glaube.
Ich ändere meinen.
Die Speicherstadt.
Flugzeug fliegt aber gut fürs Deutschland.
Also dass da nicht sooo viele gehen.
Sooo viele gehen.
Alle raus.
Wir sind nicht ermöglicht alle raus.
War ja auch vom Timing gar nicht so.
Das hatten wir vorhin auch schon mal.
Wo wir beim Auto abgehauen sind.
Und dann haben wir die Spiele gewonnen.
Da geht einer hin.
Der holt sich den.
Von Blau kommt noch einer.
Das war nichts.
Bei mir sind Gegner irgendwo.
Ich sehe sie bloß nicht.
Das war ein ziemlicher Pepega Start.
Ich krabbel mal zu euch.
Okay das war Massive.
Huge Start.
Ich mach das jetzt auch mal wie die anderen.
Ich bleib einfach im Spawn stehen und gucke in eine Richtung.
Falsche Richtung geguckt.
Das ist ein richtiger Kack Start.
Gibt es was was wir besprechen müssen?
Auf diesem Huge Runden Start.
Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen?
Das ist das neue Anonymous Video.
Ja um was gehts?
Ah sie haben irgendwas in irgendeiner Radiosende abgespielt.
Okay.
Ja wollen sie mal machen.
Ja KioKun.
Pubke war auch nicht mein Fall.
Pubke ist so ein mega langes rumgeliege.
Das schlimmste was ich mal gesehen habe war.
Pubke ein Turnier.
In Korea war das ja übelst huge.
Heute bis 22.
Ja kann schon sein.
K890.
Pubke Turnier in Korea.
Es hat dann nicht die Leute mit Kills gewonnen.
Sondern am Ende hatten die irgendwie einen Kill.
Und es hat das Squad gewonnen.
Was quasi das ganze Game in Ecke gelegen hat.
Das war das langweiligste E-Sport Turnier was ich je gesehen habe.
Und irgendwo hat auch mal einer gewonnen.
Weiß nicht was das für ein Game war.
Gibt es den PUBG?
Gibt es auch eine Gasmaske?
Dass der sich quasi.
Ich glaube das war auch PUBG.
Dass der einfach am Arsch der Welt in der Zone lag.
Und sich immer wieder neue Gasmaske gekauft hat.
Denkst du das neue Battlefield wird ein BF3 Remake?
Gibt Gerüchte?
Nein.
Glaub ich nicht.
Ich bin übrigens da.
Ich bin nur gemutet weil ich gerade mit dem Chat rede.
Also wenn ihr mich rettet bin ich sofort wieder am Start.
Ja ich seh es.
Ich seh es ja deswegen.
Pockt.
Ja ich seh es.
Ich seh es ja deswegen.
Pockt.
Legt irgendwo schon einen Drop?
Ah.
Nee.
Was jetzt?
Auf dem Dach.
Warum sind da so viele?
Onkar Giga.
Sind die tot oder sind noch da?
Nee die sind noch absolut da.
Ich bin so schlecht.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ich hab statt FG.
Da drinnen.
Aufgenommen.
Hier der andere flank bestimmt oder?
Wie viele sind das?
Ich geh mal rum.
Der ist nicht mehr aus genug Max.
Down.
Ich wollt ihn hauen.
Drohne immer noch?
Von wo?
Der steht an dem Container.
Hast du ihn?
Ich raub.
Bitte.
Ja.
Relativ close an dem LKW ist einer.
An dem LKW ist massig viel.
Da sind mindestens 4.
Hey was ist denn los?
Jetzt wollen sie das Westen.
Vorher war übelst das Gekamper und jetzt ist hier.
Den hat auch irgendjemand von mir geklappt.
Wo du mit Geld drauf treibst.
Wir können nochmal Platten kaufen.
Wir können mich kaufen.
Achso du bist noch tot.
Ich leg Geld an die Station.
Wir können ihn kaufen.
Ich bin hinter dir.
Und womit?
Mit meinem Leben.
Ich will ihn.
Ich hab volle Munition.
Woher von wo?
Und von wo kamen die?
Von vom Brünen.
Von Oben.
Die hitten alles.
Ach bei der Feuerwehr oder wo?
Ja bei der Feuerwehr.
Ja ich weiss nicht ob wird er Longrange.
Sbereit dasExcuse!
Machen wir den Timer.
Lass mal Zone.
Okay, aber die müssen doch jetzt eigentlich gleich raus aus der Feuerwehr ja ich sehe sie runter hüpfen
oh, hinter uns war was
nein okay kann nichts mehr sein
okay
trendsetter hier
habe auch null platten
exzellent
ich habe die armor box ich habe sie mitgenommen
ich weiß ganz genau dass du die nicht mitgenommen
ich habe sie mitgenommen
Der war ja richtig krass.
Da vorne rechts, wir fahren jetzt gegen einen entlang.
Kannst du mal hier hart sein, beim Schaufeln.
Ja, ein blauer ist ein Gegner.
Bewege dich, bewege dich, bewege dich.
Sollen wir die Bänden fahren draus machen,
dann haben wir einen relativ guten Überblick.
Ah ja, hier vorne.
Links, links, links, links, du lässt den holen.
Der ist über uns, über uns.
Nee, der steht hier über uns.
Oh, auf dem Dach.
Passt auf, auf dem Dach gegenüber.
An blau auf dem Dach, Achtung.
Da kommen noch, da sind noch mehr.
Wir sind hier noch tot.
Wir sollten eigentlich einfach wegfahren.
Nee, lass mal den Typen holen.
Was?
Da.
Hier, hinter den Kisten, hinter den Kisten.
Genau dahinter.
Ich hab Land.
Wo seid ihr?
Wir sind noch mehr.
Also, wie gesagt, an blau auf dem Dach war vorhin noch einer.
Das könnte der gewesen sein.
Wo sollen wir hin, oder wo sollen wir bleiben?
Da muss ich mich nicht wieder rübercrossen.
Komm, lass wegfahren.
Nimm mal so, da hat ein C4 auf uns geworfen.
Und das Trophy-System hat ihn.
Warum, warum ich denn da?
Dann scheint er nicht.
Drei, zwei, eins, ich verlos.
Alter, was ist das?
Achtung, das sind, hinter der Maus sind Leute.
Ja.
Vor links, vor links.
Ist Trophy noch aktiv?
Jaja, aber hat schon, hat schon
hat schon einen oder zwei Dinger geholt.
Ich hör einen V4-Motor.
Da vorne ist einer vorne.
Vorne, vorne Jungs, verroschen.
Oh, ich hab einmal gehitted.
Poggers vom ganzen Magazin.
Was?
Ich dachte wir killen den jetzt.
Ja, ich dachte auch.
Ich fahr nur das Auto weg.
Jetzt wird er.
Hahaha
Huge Timing.
Oh, vor dem...
Fuck, Alter.
What? Okay.
Ah, Mann. Warum ficken die uns immer
von der Seite so weg?
Am Arsch der Welt.
Okay, das war jetzt doof.
Also das...
Nee, gar nicht bei so...
Ja, auch von uns, aber dass die wieder den ganzen Tag
da sitzen, Alter.
Ach so, wir leben ja noch.
So ein bisschen.
Okay, wir sind alle gewiped gerade.
Ich kann mich nicht sehen, wenn ich sie nicht sehen kann.
Oh, mit Minus ein Leben.
Mo, guck mal, spotte mal bitte.
Ah ja.
Spotte mal bitte bei mir.
Wo bist du, Urs? Oder da?
Besonders, ich hab Max noch gerettet.
Ich hab die Denpex komplett gefressen.
Und bin auch noch weggekommen, obwohl da
zwei Typen mich hätte sehen müssen.
Also, ich feier's nicht so, wo du bist.
Mit oder ohne Waffen.
Du sollst ja nur spotten.
Ich versuch's.
Du versuchst es nicht genug, genug.
Okay, über mich sind da Gegner.
Ich bin ernst.
Da ist einer, oder?
Ich seh da nix.
Mir pixelst er einfach nur.
Weißt du?
Er schaut so ein bisschen näher an.
Da ist keiner.
Jetzt fallt schon was.
Da, links, ich find Kaufstation.
Kaufstation.
Luft, Luft, Luft.
Rechts bei Max.
Das ist mein Loot.
Egal.
Ich hab noch meinen eigenen auch noch.
Wo ist meiner? Da?
Hallo, Loot.
Eins und zwei.
Und das.
Okay, Zone kommt.
Ich hab keine Schuss.
Gib mir dein Loot!
Give money!
Sonst krieg ich Loot.
Ich hab's gerade erst gemerkt.
Haha, sag bloß, da geht's nicht hoch.
Ihr müsst links rum.
Viel Spaß.
Ich hab nur noch ne Sniper, man.
Ich bin richtig useful.
Bist du auch mitmuniziert?
Ja, komm hier.
Hier kriegst du ein Plättchen und...
Alter, wie süß bist du eigentlich?
Du hast ne Karte.
Hier kriegst du ein Plättchen und...
Alter, wie süß bist du eigentlich?
Du hast ne Karre.
Oder ne Rettung.
Ja, genau, weil da ja noch...
Ey, zum Glück ist die Zone so richtig nicht oft und wir müssen da nicht durchlaufen.
Ah, links sind so viele Gegner.
Rechts, sorry.
Dann...
Egal, aber ich bin ja Sniper-Bot-HDX.
Ja, Snipes einfach alle in den Kopf, wenn gut ist.
Oh, Chat, das war richtig unglückliche Kacke gerade.
Wieder voll in die Gegner gefahren.
Vierer Team sitzt oben in der Ecke.
Wären wir mal abgesprungen, wo ich abgesprungen bin?
Also, wären wir mal alle abgesprungen, wo ich abgesprungen bin?
Dann...
Dann wären wir denen zumindest nicht direkt ins Aim gerannt.
Aber nachher ist man immer schlauer, ne?
Die Hälfte der Games gewonnen heute, kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Die Cup, legit, on stream.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Die mahnen das jetzt schon, easy win.
Die Viera mit der Schneibe, warum stellst du der?
Schauen wir uns den TS an.
Falls ich nicht welche Fragen übersehen habe, schreibt sie doch mal rein.
Kann sein, dass ich heute nicht so viel sehe.
Ich hab schon alles.
Ich hab acht.
Ich hab einen Platten.
Komm mit, das kann ich so mitzeigen.
Wir können beide nicht kaufen, aber einen.
Jetzt können wir beide kaufen.
Jetzt können wir beide kaufen, aber einen.
links
ganz hinten
oh oh oh
wo sind die hier los?
wissen wir nicht
sind die hier wahrscheinlich schon
aus der überraschung
oh mein
ein war
nice
oh mein
oh Gott
ich geh jetzt voll auf
direkt neben euch ist eine Kaufi
oh oh
oh mein
Ich versuche dich zu retten.
Über dir, Max. Über dir ist auch noch einer. Oh, der kommt her. Wo denn? Über uns, da hinten. Ich kann nicht markieren. Dann merke ich. Der ist gelandet, der ist gerade gelandet. Gib mal Max wenigstens eine Waffe von deinen Moments. Die kommen rechts, die kommen rechts, die kommen rechts. Die kommen da, die kommen da. Ich habe nur eine Sniper. Ja, dann hau ab. Ich habe keine Platten und ich habe nur eine Sniper.
Max, du hast meine Waffe gekriegt. Ja. Mach was draus. Halt den Putsch hier.
Ich muss zum Drop. Sniper ist so da oben. Ich kann den Grau noch mal holen. Ja, ich habe, ich hole mir auch noch meine Grau. Da, da, da. Pass auf, links.
Links ist auch noch was. Links ist ganz schön viel.
Ich habe Max alle Munition gegeben. Ich habe nur 5 Schuss. Nein, ich habe die 210 hingelegt.
Dann hast du es getroppt, nachdem ich losgerannt bin. Beste, ja. Ich gehe jetzt einfach zum Drop und hole mir was.
Ach du heiliglich. Ist der bei dir? Oder ist er down? Der guckt Richtung Moritz an die Leiche. Der guckt da schon noch runter.
Du hast auf mich geschossen. Ja, ja. Ich habe dein Aimplate nicht gesehen. Der ist oben, der guckt ab und zu noch mal runter. Versuche nicht mit dem Laser oben drüber zu gehen. Das ist ein roter Laser, den sieht er nicht.
Den roten sieht man nicht. Den grünen sehen die nur. Aber den sieht man auf dem Parkour. Max, mach mal bitte.
Armored Break ist runtergehüpft. Der ist links runtergehüpft. Sony, push den. Ja, ja.
Wow, RPG. Bunker. Links ist noch. Fuck, fuck, wir müssen hier raus. Einer bei uns, Klaus.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Fucking RPG. Heute ruhiges Gameplay. 6500 Schaden. 5 RPG, Alter.
Das war bitter. Halt doch komplett auf, wenn du bist hier.
Ihr musst komplett über die Straße drüber laufen. Was willst du? Kannst nichts große machen.
Du hast doppelt RPG spammt. Weiß gar nicht, warum die so viele RPGs am Start hatten am Rundenende.
Verdansk. Irgendwie bug das übelst. Manchmal kann ich muten und manchmal nicht. Warum?
Weil es ein sehr gutes Programm ist. Ich hab's ja gemapt auf Minus. Jetzt geht's wieder nicht.
Weil dich die Tastatur vielleicht umstellt. Mir stellt die sich immer auf Endlösung.
Tatsächlich? WTF? Was ist das denn? Was ist? Das mit dem Alt, wegen dem Altdrücken ist das.
Ich hab auch noch so einen Spielemodus, aber selbst der kann das nicht auffängen.
Wo lernt man die World Record Gameplays? Noch nicht, meinste?
Wo lernt man was? Ich wollte Apache machen und da unten war ein Gegner und ich hatte sie echt schon gut im Visier.
Ich wollte gerade abdrücken und dann zieht Moos den Helikopter in die Grenze und ich schieß schon in die Füße.
Ich glaub diesmal ist Storage Town nicht so das. Wobei warum eigentlich nicht, wenn wir laufen müssen wir laufen.
Da müssen wir halt laufen, das ist ja kein Problem. Das Problem ist Patrick, warum das da nicht funktioniert.
Ich hab hier englische Sprache und deutsches Layout und ich glaub ich kann die Sprache nicht löschen ohne das Layout zu löschen.
Also, Gemma?
Ich hab noch ein Video, dann hab ich meine YouTube-Dance vergessen und hab nicht so viel gemacht.
Hier ist ja nichts drin.
Okay, hier ist mir das sehr sehr spärlich alles.
Das Ding ist wirklich, vor allem das macht noch nicht mal richtig Damage am Endeffekt wenn du driffst.
Oh guck mal, ich nehm jetzt auch mal ein RPG.
Oh die brauch ich.
Es sind ja fast alle, also die Hälfte.
Was kommt als nächstes? Twitter Periscope oder was?
Ah soll die mal machen.
Oh es laggt, der Surfer laggt.
Nice Leute.
Wie schnell bitte, gegenüber von dem Scheiß-Dual.
Also das war echt, was war das?
Das beste, den brauchen wir jetzt noch.
Mir egal.
Aber das war wirklich obvious, also der hat so schnell und so krass reingehauen.
Also wieso spielen wir das, der wird uns ehrlich fühlen.
Ich hab jetzt niemanden, der meinen Clip rein schicken kann, sonst würde ich ihn ja schicken.
Wo war mal ein schön?
Was hat der überhaupt für eine Waffe gehabt?
Ist alles weg.
Oh der Surfer ruckelt.
Oder der laggt.
Wo ist das Loot?
Das ist immerhin besser als nichts.
Oh der hinten schießt schon hoch.
Man, ich dachte die hauen weg.
Oh, nice.
Wo ist der?
Hier klinger.
Ich geb sofort die Raketen her
Raketen hier
Wo ist der letzte?
Ich hab auch einen Raketenwerfer
Der Server laggt
Der hat meinen Raketenwerfer geklaut
Bei mir laggt der auch nicht
Okay
Der laggt da
Ja, aber der hat kein Skin
Der laggt da mit, ob sie die auch noch auf dem Boden holen
Ha
Oh, von den Steppers dahinten
Lass mal in den Gunter reingehen
Ungeludet
Wie dieses komische Scheiß-Fanzosen-Team
Oh mein Gott
Die waren toll
Oh, die aimen uns ab
Richtig, richtig heftig
Mit 3x Sniper
Die haben Triple Sniper
Irgendwie geflankt
Der flankt hier rechts
Hinterm Baum
Down, Down
Ist unter uns einer oder nicht?
Könnte sein, dass er sich Self Revived hat
Der liegt da schon auf der Straße
Häh? Okay nice. Da unten war er. Alter, wie der da rumgekrebst ist.
Ich wechsle nicht den, ich wechsle nicht die Sniper.
Haben wir noch eben so ein armor-stacheln-Ding? Hatte keiner von uns.
Im 13 kommst du Papa.
Lass uns mal das Kopfgeld holen.
Okay.
Ah, hier liegt noch eine grau. Sehr viel, Alter.
Hat, hat anyone some plates?
Nee.
Da oben liegen noch mehr Platten bei den Platten.
Ich hab drei.
Hier sind noch Platten aus, da.
Wo?
Da hinten, da hinten lagen noch mehr Platten.
Egal.
Geil.
Oder nicht. Nee, ich glaub's.
Hier liegt noch eine M4 und eine MP3.
Hatte gerade irgendwas mit Sprengsatz gesagt?
Ich hab auch eine MP3 geworden.
Okay.
Ach, die geil. Liebe dich.
Also, ich hab vier Platten. Wenn du unbedingt was brauchst, kann dir was geben.
Ich hab ne Munikiste. Ich dropp sie hier.
Noch eine. Wir haben doch schon eine oben liegen gehabt.
Der ist weg. Für Cedrics.
Ich hab den nicht mehr dabei. Ich hab den nicht mehr dabei.
Auf was? Das enttäuscht mich jetzt noch mal.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Ja.
Okay.
Wo wollen wir hin?
Ich weiß nicht.
Da rüber?
Ja, da rüber.
Ich kauf mal ne Drohne.
Nee, die brauchst du Platten.
Ich brauch 1500. Danach kauf ich mir selber Platten.
Ja, ich leg dir 3000, komm.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, welchen ich mag.
Du musst mir gern dein ganzes Geld jetzt geben.
Ja.
War voll nett.
Ich weiß nicht auch mal, wie sich das anfühlt.
Ah, so ein paar UAVs. Kann man auch schon.
Doch, Klasserschlag.
Das ist ja nichts mehr.
Ich versteh nicht, wie Klasserschlag illiger ist als Airstrike.
Naja, bei der Klasserschlag nicht, wo er hin soll.
Drei mal Plates. Drei mal Plates.
Ja, und da ist auch noch Muni drin, gell?
Ja.
Ah, ich hol mir nochmal die Plates jetzt.
Ach, du hast es schon, oder?
Nee, nee.
Wollen wir jetzt den Kopfgeld machen?
Ja.
Haben wir noch ein UAV?
Nee.
Ah, wir können noch nix leisten.
Wir haben safe Geld für uns.
Neoplex ist bestimmt schon am Stadion jetzt.
Wir müssen aufpassen.
Ah, Neoplex.
Hör auf, Neoplex.
Der ist Neoplex.
Der Cheater.
Neoplex ist der Cheater, mit dem wir mal gespielt haben.
Und seitdem ist jeder Cheater Neoplex.
Das ist eines der ersten Sachen, die Ramire erzählt hat.
Das weiß ich, wenn du es gemerkt hast, dass der Cheater ist.
Das ist so ein allgemeiner Call.
Ich hab mal gegen einen Cheater gespielt und der hat sich vor einem scheiß Traum holen lassen.
Der ist einfach gestorben am Ende und wir haben das alle gefeiert.
Es war glaube ich 2 gegen 1, also er gegen 2 oder so, oder 1.
Und er wurde dann vor einem Auto überfahren, weil er zuvor war.
Ob unser Ziel etwa Campers sind?
Kann nicht sein.
Wir können auch einfach da hoch gehen, gell?
Und dann von hier hinten rein.
Oh, die wollen dahin, die wollen dahin, die wollen dahin.
Ich will eigentlich sagen, wir haben 33 Sekunden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das schaffen.
Wir wissen, wo die sind.
Aber die haben jetzt Angst, weil die Farbe sich ändert von ihrem...
Ich hab 250 Meter, erinnert sich das auf den...
Da sind jetzt 60.
Ah ja, ok.
Oder 150.
Wow.
Nice.
Neoplex, du Schnus.
Stefan Miao.
Er heißt Stefan Miao.
Lasst doch die Furry Community in Ruhe.
Langs, dass kein Reh ist.
Gibt es da irgendeine Frohgeschichte?
Ja.
Aber das kann ich jetzt auf Twitch nicht erzählen.
Twitch ist da sensitiv, was das angeht, mit Rehen.
Wie mit Rehen?
Ich check's irgendwie nicht.
Gebt einfach Twitch Reh ein, dann werde ich es später bereuen.
War das Teamweb?
Nein, das war einer, der misspawnt wurde.
Wir haben jetzt zwei gekauft, einen hab ich davon geholt.
35 Meter geradeaus.
3 Leute, oh mein Gott, 3 Leute da.
Ich bin mit dir hier oben.
Da, einer kommt drunter.
Wir haben wieder einen gekauft.
Wir können von oben die Locker holen.
Ich komme mit, ich gehe hoch.
Das tue ich mir nicht an.
Unter uns, 3 Stück genau unter uns.
What the fuck, was ist das denn?
Wir wissen, dass die oben sind.
Die können rechts und links raus.
Hey, ich schieße noch einen Sniper auf mich.
Ah.
Feind.
Die sichern, die sichern, die sichern.
Oh nein, was mache ich denn?
Ich bin mit 3 im Haus drin.
Okay, dann sichern die halt nicht.
Hier unten im Haus.
Ich bin unten im Haus.
Okay, ich gehe da jetzt rein.
Ich renne mit UMP rein.
Alter, wo geht es hier hoch in diesen Dreck?
Du bist so dumm, warum gehst du nicht aus dem Haus raus?
Du bist so dumm.
Hier ist einer auf der Treppe.
Oh shit.
Einer auf der Treppe hier.
Da muss er sein irgendwo.
What the heck?
Noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe 2 Hops genommen.
Die gehen auf Top, die Idioten.
Die haben einen Top geholt.
Was zum Teufel?
Wo kommt der her?
Hier oben, oben Gegner bei uns.
Was geht mir den Gegner an?
Ich habe unten die Tür aufgemacht.
Ich glaube Max, oder?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wieso geht der während einem Fight viel gegen viel raus und wirft einen Drop?
Was ey?
Der eine lag hier ganz hinten in der Ecke mit nichts.
Aber ich habe immer noch vorne welche sichern.
Okay.
Ich spüre jetzt mal wieder Sniper.
Das ist ein guter Engel.
Da hinten rechts waren vorher Gegner.
Hier oben.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Siehst du, auf unserer Maus.
Auf unserer Maus.
Komm mal da hoch jetzt.
Ich nehme mich an.
Kann sein, dass hier etwas kommt.
Ich bin ganz unten.
Los hier.
Nein.
Bitte.
Die sind draußen.
Ich sterbe jetzt.
Schön mit euch gelebt haben.
Nein.
Jetzt ist er hinter mir.
Was ein scheiß Timing.
Ich hasse.
Was eine Kacke.
Ich dachte ich kriege dich doch.
Und dann kommt er auch noch auf den gleichen Ort um die Ecke.
Zwei.
Hammer.
So heroisch wie ich es hätte gerettet.
Dann muss ich das nochmal machen.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Weißt du wo Max?
Oh mein Gott ich sterbe.
Die sind direkt um die Ecke noch.
Hier zwei Leute.
Nice.
Noch einer.
Noch einer Moritz.
Habe sie doch schon.
Rest einfach.
Rest auch erstmal.
Komm doch.
Du hast hier so ein wildes Reh.
Der Zoom ist doch richtig.
Wo ist das?
Ich habe auch Kokain.
Kokain beste.
Chat das das teilweise echt anstrengt.
Hatten die noch mehr Geld?
Nee oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich dachte noch einer komm unten.
Das habe ich schon gehört CD.
Die waren ja leider weiter da oben drin.
Und wahrscheinlich.
Was war das denn?
Ein Internet.
Hack ist angeschlagen.
Wo ist denn meine Waffe?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Hier liegt aber alles was du willst und noch viel mehr.
Außer Geld.
Bei euch, wo ihr gestorben seid.
Vielleicht habt ihr noch Geld.
Ich kann mal rausgehen wo ihr hauptsächlich seid.
Wo ist er?
Moritz.
Der kommt schon wieder.
Du musst jetzt rein.
Der holt gleich eure Zeug.
Hast du noch so eine?
Da hast du den Busch.
Der war da oben drauf.
Ja.
Ich habe keinen Herzstack mehr.
Da sind zwei Leute drin oder?
Ja da sind zwei Leute drin.
Warum seid ihr denn nicht zusammen?
Ich weiß nicht warum Moritz da genau ist.
Ich bin erst mal hier.
Ich habe nur den Luftschrank geholt.
Wtf warum?
Wenn ich den drauf gehauen habe und ihr nicht nochmal drauf fahren wollt.
Welche Dachse sind noch auf dem Dach?
Hier ist Storage Town.
Da ist noch eine.
Aber chat ich muss sagen es wird.
Ich weiß noch wie lost ich mich gefühlt habe.
Vor ungefähr
1,5 Wochen wo ich wieder angefangen habe zu spielen.
Mittlerweile geht es halbwegs an.
Geht aufwärts.
Neoplext der Party Joint.
Ich bin hier.
Oh fuck.
Der Cluster haut doch eine Station vom Haus auch drauf.
Eigentlich wenn ihr den da hin haust,
dann könnten die da drauf gehen oder?
Die sind unter mir.
Guck mal.
Alle.
Geil.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Ich glaube die sind unten.
Ich habe rechts noch einen Herzstack.
Rechts draußen liege ich.
Ich bin hier.
Los.
Erstmal auf die Uhr kommen.
Wo warst du denn?
Wurfmesser abwürfen.
Wurfmesser putt camp.
Womit campen die nicht?
Die holen einfach alles.
Die haben die Ruhe weg.
Der hat alles Geld erweckt.
Der war ja arm.
Der war richtig arm.
Komische Welt.
Leg dich in das Loot rein. Du musst versteckt sein.
Ohne Witz.
Die haben sie doch nie.
Um die?
Egal.
Gut, dass ich den Fallschirm benutzen kann wie ein normaler Mensch
und nicht wie so eine Hütte.
Ich bin in die Hütte.
Jetzt warte.
Ich dusche.
War nicht so klug.
Doch.
Der ist doch zu groß.
Da kommt einer câmera gehen.
Du bist ja wie ein Mohun
Du bist echt wie ein Mohun, bei Max laufen die immer rein
Vollschul-Code-Gamplay
Machst du eine Gasmaske?
Ja, schaff ich ja nicht, kannste hin
Die haben nochmal eine Gasmaske wahrscheinlich, oder?
Du bist doch nur...
Warte mal, drei Teams, sechs Spieler
Gegen fünf Leute, drei Teams
Heißt, keiner...
Ein Vierer
Und ein Einser
Oh, Stand, Stand von rechts
Stand am Belkan
Ich muss schon nicht weit laufen
Dann, genau in der Mitte von der Zone
Stand aufs links, stand aufs links
Ja
Das war der Einzelne
Ja, der geht übelst ab
Tony the Beat
Ich glaub, der hat mehr Damage als wir alle zusammen
die Runde
Guck mal
Die haben irgendwie viele Frags, die da campen
Bestimmt da keine
Bestimmt der erste, oder so
Viel Spaß
Das war der Einzelne, oder?
Gegen ein Dreier-Team
Die standen ineinander
Ja, da machst du nichts, da machst du nichts
Vier Kills
Aber huge
Nochmal richtig, richtig nice
am Ende
Ihr seid so krank
Oh, ihr scheiß Bruder
Erst wenn die Lobby am Ende ist, kannst du das sehen
Wie viele Frags, man, hatten die
Oder der eine hat
Das kann man gleich nachgucken
Wo denn?
Auf der Seite kannst du nachgucken
Wie viele Kills die Gegner von Teams haben
Sekunde
Wir gucken uns mal kurz den
Hexor an aus letzter Runde
Der uns alle, der uns Teamwiped hat
Ich muss schnell das aufmachen
Oh man, ich bin so traurig
Ich bin so traurig
Ja, das ist einfach das Dreier-Team
Einfach wirklich so
Die standen in der Milchstraße
Wo kann man das erzählen?
Wie glorreich die da
Gewonnen haben gerade
Also in dem Spiel davor
Also in dem Spiel davor, wo wir Vierter
geworden sind am Ende
Das erste Team 19
Dann 23, dann 25, wir Vierter
Mit 25
Danach waren nur noch 13, 9, 6
Waren wirklich die besten vier Teams
Hast du den Clip?
Jawollo
Wo ist der drin?
Teilen und
Den Link
In welchem Chat?
Ich schicke ihn
Mir egal, du kannst ihn auch in Twitch chat posten
Ah hier, passt
Ich hab's
Da waren zwei Leute da wieder
Komplett im Haus campen
Und dann als andere Team zu dritt
Da hinten
Das ist halt bitter
Jetzt los
Ich hätte die einfach vielleicht lassen müssen
Das zwei Team
Aber zwei Easy-Freaks kann ich mir immer machen
Das legt ja noch nicht
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Haha
Ja ist klar
Moment
Jetzt kommt die Killcam
Der ist direkt nochmal auf den Kopf
Getwitcht so
Oh man
Legit
MLG legit
Haha
Oh man
Legit
MLG legit
Haha
Holy cow, Alter
Du hast aber nicht ein bisschen Endzugs geschossen
Ja
Dafür waren drei andere Box
Die da wirklich mit der Sniper
Aber was willst du, machen wir das dann
Aber es nervt aber trotzdem
Einfach bessere Spiele
In der Normalfall
Vielleicht ein entspannter Gegner
Ja, aber was ich auch mit den anderen gemacht habe
Ich habe alle da abgeklärt
Ich habe eigentlich da einen gemischert und einen geklärt
Ich habe nur den zweiten geklärt
Dann wieder das andere Team
Und dann wieder das andere Team
Wir geben dir so eine Ratte
Und was sieht das glaube ich
Oder
Der hat dich getötet, weißt du noch den Namen
Alex oder Craned oder
Mich am Ende
Wie kürzt du dann bei dem in der Killcam
Oder waschst du dann bei dem in dem
Ja, nach dem Spiel kann ich nachgucken
Weil dann ist das andere Spiel mit drin
Okay
Ich habe auch schon was
Hey, ich glaube
Dein Team im Stream
Hat es doch nicht verstanden
Wahrscheinlich
Wo bist du?
Da bin ich
Was ist eigentlich diese
Diese Emotes, die dann irgendwas anderes abschlecken
Was ist eigentlich
Seit wann geht das
Wenn man Better TwitchTV oder FFZ installieren kann
Wenn du es nicht installiert hast, dann siehst du es aber eigentlich auch nicht
Ach du hast es installiert
Ach so
Ja das sind so custom
Emotes, die haben mit Twitch nichts zu tun
Ich glaube sowas wird Twitch auch nicht unbedingt als Emote machen
Normalerweise
Was haben wir denn hier
Zum Teufel, was ist das
Ich habe es nicht mehr hingekriegt
Ich bin zu schlecht
Was ist
Die Oden
Ach das ist die Oden
Krasses Hipfire die Oden
Huge Hipfire
Sniper Scope und mit Sniper Visier
Sniper Scope und mit Riesenschalldämpfe
Die verzieht schon krass
Aber die macht halt kranken Schaden
Du musst damit echt tappen
Was waren
Die
Computerspieler oder was waren das
Mensch
Die Letzten
Ich schätze Xbox
So wie die geglacert haben
Alter die Oden
Aber ich möchte ja mal wissen
Was das dritte Team da gemacht hat
Wie können die so schlecht sein und dritter werden
Wahrscheinlich 0 Kills
Wie ist das mit blindem Huen
Was auch mal was findet
Das übliche
Exzellent
Also ich muss jetzt echt sagen
So mit wireless Maus nach ein paar Tagen
Es geht
Viel besser als ohne
Also besser ist tatsächlich
Mein mag jetzt super klar klingen
Wenn der Kabel dran ist
Du meinst du solltest auch mal dem eine Chance geben
Omega Brain
Sixhead
Und Keyboard auch kabellos
Keyboard ist doch völlig scheißegal
Wenn das auf dem Tisch geht
Die ganze Zeit
Dann nimmst du deine Maus mit
Wohin oder
In die Küche
Das waren alles Computerspieler
Oh hier landen
Einige
Hier ist gar nichts
Hinter mir ist einer
Hier ist nichts, hier ist keine Waffe
Nichts
Hier eine Pharma
Exzellent
Ich versteck mich hier
Absolut bereit
Ganz ehrlich kann ich da hin
Ich hab hier eine Armour
Prakt
Ich versuch dich zu holen
Armour prakt
Ich muss helfen
Ich glaub der flankt
Ich glaub der flankt einer
Ich hab einfach die alle drei mit bestandet
Moritz ich lag da wo du gerade lagst
Der kam rein und hat sich umgeschossen
Der flankt
Das sind drei Stück Boys Team Jungs
Key kap und abfahren
Ab zum Bunker
Ich hab die
Die sind da links
Ich hab die keykat gefunden
Ich bin hinter euch
Der grüne da
Ja was denn, was soll ich machen
Ich frag nur ob du da bist
Du bist am Boden schon oder
Ja
Weil ich dachte ich lag hinter denen
Lag oben drauf auf dem Ding
Das ist ein guter Plan
Wir könnten die auch weg machen
Ja okay
Ab zum Damm würde ich sagen
Oder zum Military
Wir hauen ab
Nix wie weg
Hauptsache noch mal was umfahren
Ja G-Bro hab ich am Start
Nicht Pro sondern G-Bro
Was ist denn hier los
Hier ist nix
Ich hüpf außen raus
Wenn du da mit dem Auto lang fährst
Achso warum
Ja dann ich laufe in die Richtung
Fahr schon mal
Das reicht nicht der Tunnel ist zu lang
Ich glaub das geht schon
Der ist halt lang in der Tunnel
Ich hol dir das Loot dann passt das
Ich muss dafür wissen wo der Tunnel liegt
Welcher Tunnel wir gehen Lila
Oder wir gehen hier
Lila oder da
Lila
Kommt ihr ran oder wie
Ich bin gleich da
Ah da ist er
Call of Duty für 6
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo er überhaupt davon spricht
Ich kann nicht sehen wieviel Kanalpunkt jemand hat
Ich hab keine Mittelfinger
So das denn jetzt
Oh mein Gott wir haben keine Tunnel
Ja ja da ist nix
Du brauchst dann deinen Move sagt er, Chat
Wir haben die Stoffe setzten.
Okay.
Ja, das wird ihn.
Um, um, um.
Danke.
Wer killt uns jetzt?
Okay, Poggers, Poggers.
Wer denn da auch rausspringen soll?
Oder weiter fahren?
Ich wollte doch fahren, aber wer ist rausgeflogen?
Ich bin, ich nicht.
Wer hat den Keycard?
Dann lasst uns den Bungo kippen.
Wenn die gegen an ihm.
Ach.
Das ist jemand von euch Bullarge gerade?
Ja, der kommt rein.
Okay.
Ich bin dran, ich bin dran.
Der kommt von dir rechts.
Geht auf dir an, ist in Mitte, Mitte.
Was?
Ja, sowas hatte ich vorhin auch.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, what the fuck, wie geht das?
Ich weiß, wie das geht.
Der hat sowas in der Hand.
Wo nicht aussieht wie eine Maus.
Mit so zwei Sticks.
Wurde dann nur so ganz grob in der Nase.
Ey, wir haben einen Gegner von denen gekillt.
Ja, ich hab einen geholt.
Ja cool, danke für die Waffen.
Bitte.
Base station 5 Event wurde verschoben.
Max, renn mal da zu dem Einkostwagen hin.
Und mach mal was Gutes.
Okay.
Wo seid ihr denn überhaupt?
Ja, ich bin gleich beim Bunker.
Also das PS5 Event wurde gerade verschoben.
Was ist denn PS5 Event, man?
Die Vorstellner.
Und wer will gewestet werden?
Ich, weil ich hab deine Waffe besorgt.
Ich hab mich gekillt.
Das hilft gar nicht.
Fuck, wohl seh die.
Ach, da unten?
Ich hab mich gekillt
mit der Standardliste.
Drei.
Ich muss nochmal betonen.
Ne, ne.
Schreibs907, danke für den Sub.
11 Monate.
Wahnsinn.
Will jemand den grauen?
Der spielt die genau wie ich.
Ich würde den nehmen.
Du bist doch nicht mal am lieben.
Hier, ich geb euch bald mal ne Platte.
Hast du mir auch ein Stückchen Munition?
Also ganz ehrlich, was willst du denn noch, oder?
Nein, okay, passt. Ich hab 60 Schuss in der grauen.
Okay.
Einfach geht es.
Let's go.
Ja, was machen die da mit dem Bunker?
Wo haben wir denn die Karte gebrochen?
Die Joden, die gehen da gar nicht rein.
Wo ist denn der?
Ja, hier links.
Danke.
Lass kurz das Äffel aufräumen.
Ich übergebe euch die Leitungen.
Was bist du denn nicht für ne Ratte gewesen, Cedric?
Erstmal schön finishen die Schweine, ne?
Der einzige Ausweg aus der Situation,
dass die wenigstens noch
einmal tilt sind.
Dass der Maid im T.S. tilt und sagt
warum finishen und lassen sie mich finishen?
Psychologische Kriegsführer sozusagen.
Das machen die doch auch die ganze Zeit.
Hier hat keiner Bock auf den Bunker.
Wir wissen gar nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das so genau wissen,
weil
vorhin haben wir auch ganz schön
lang draufgesucht.
Wenn die YouTube Videos keine Ahnung haben,
dann keine Ahnung.
Warum steht auf dem ganzen Map, dass es 8 oder 9
Bunker gibt, aber jeden zwei?
Wo ist das?
Ein Auto von hinten?
Das kommt hier lang.
Ja, ich hab ihn am Hüpfen sehen.
Okay, ist er wieder weg ein bisschen?
Weg, okay.
Let's see you again.
Das ist ein bisschen besser.
Ja.
Die mögen mich nicht.
Die schießen voll hinten.
Lass mal den Healy nehmen.
Und dazu sichern.
Und einfach abzuhauen danach?
Ja, wir sichern und dann hauen wir ab.
Au!
Boah.
Wie läuft's bei dir, merkst du?
Ich werd nicht sagen, aber wer stirbt verreckt?
Ich.
Magst du hinter mir laufen?
Beste Timing.
Komm rein.
Ja, mit drin.
Weg rein, Weg rein.
Im Hangar, ja.
Boah, die pushen uns.
Wir können das nicht machen.
Die sind schon halb auf dem Weg da.
Was?
Die sind schon hier.
Ah, doch, das schaffen wir.
Sichert mal, ich cover.
Wir können hinten rein, wir können hinten rein.
Alles gut, sichert mal.
Ich cover.
Außer da liegt jetzt ein 4er-Team, überraschungsweise.
Hier, da sind die!
Hopp!
Du machst das schon.
Lass dann aber auch hinten wieder raus, Max.
Jaja.
Heatbreak!
Okay, lass ihn wieder raus.
Wir sind hinten wieder raus, wir können zum HG wegen mir.
Das reicht absolut noch nicht für Moritz.
Wo?
Irgendwo.
Heatbreak.
Exzellent.
Bei einem Assault Rifle muss ich da gar nicht gegen anstecken.
Ja, okay, egal.
Es rennt.
Ohne schlechte Arme.
Ich hol den kurz, ich hol den kurz.
Das ist doof.
So platziert.
Ja, ich würde das dann nicht machen.
Hast du da nicht gerade das halbe Team abgefuckt, wo wir jetzt hinfliegen müssen?
Na klar.
Okay.
Links!
Mach nicht, mach nicht, mach nicht.
Warum?
Das ist unglücklich.
Links ist einer.
Ja.
Der Mann hier.
Da.
Aber ich glaube, über dir war noch ein Stern, oder?
Da, bei Lila.
Lass mal sichern, lass mal schön sichern, komm.
Die feiten halt auf das andere Team.
Der Lila wird gerade aufgehoben.
Komm mit!
Das ist ja nicht schneller als das.
Was?
Ich hab wieder das Reh gemacht.
Was geht?
Aber guck mal, ihr habt immer den Objekt, aber ihr habt ihn noch nie gekauft.
Oha, oha Schatz.
Wir sind auf der anderen Seite.
Oh!
Alter.
Gulasch.
Hahaha, Sau.
Weg damit.
Oh mein Gott, ich bin tot, ich bin tot.
Wo, wo, wo, wo?
Ja, die schicken mich auf.
Nein, nein, ich komm.
Ich leg unten, ich leg am
Hintereingang, oder soll ich vorne hin?
Soll ich vorne raus, oder?
Ich weiss nicht, ich weiss nicht.
Wie komm ich dahin?
Egal, wo du reingehst, leg in der Mitte.
Die kommen halt einfach nicht.
Du kannst sie nerven.
Die werden uns zerstoßen.
Hey Max, wie geht es dir?
Cool.
Da, wenn wir rechts rausgucken,
löchle ich ein Sternchen.
Leuchle ich ein Sternchen.
Ja, ich bin doch da.
Mennen.
Wir sind da, wir haben es geschafft.
Weg.
Da oder so, da.
Eigentlich würde ich gehen nur auf den Loot, den ich befinde.
Ich brauch Munition, man.
Ja, also Muni ist nicht so
viel.
Ja, unten fährt ein Auto.
Lass halt Muni-Box
tauchen.
Ah, scheiße, ein Moritz.
Wir haben genug, oder? Wie viel kostet die Muni-Box?
Passt für euch.
Geh mal raus und holt ihn, man.
Ich dropp, ich dropp.
Wo ist der?
Der shop hier, hä?
So ein Moritz, meinst du.
Versteh ich nur.
Jetzt hat Muni.
Ja, genau, ich hab nur bekommen.
Ich kauf Platten hier.
Fünf Platten hier.
Ich kann noch mal Geld trinken.
Mo, du hast 1.700.
Gut, dass wir ihn geholt haben.
Mal gucken, ob hier noch
irgendwas in der Links legt.
Links da.
Auto, hinter uns.
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, ich nehm mich selber mit der Waffe.
Sollen wir laufen mit den Füßen?
Hab ihn ausgenommen, Klub.
Können wir ihn finnischen?
Ich bin auch so gut mit der Pistole, aber
trotzdem wär's besser.
Und weg mit dem.
Hock.
Ich will doch nur warten.
Hier liegt jede Menge.
Soll ich einen Hedy holen?
Nein, wir holen ihn noch ab.
Wollen wir mal eine Muni Box kaufen?
No joke.
Platin-MP.
Lass mal wirklich Muni Box.
Alles meine Kohle liegt hier.
Ich nehm auf.
Geld, Geld, Geld.
Mo, komm her, wir brauchen dein Geld.
Ja, aber für mich wird gesniped.
Mir auch egal.
Geld, Geld.
Und abhauen, abhauen.
Haben wir die Muni Box.
Der Hedy ist sowas von nicht safe.
Der ist safe, der ist safe, der ist safe.
Der ist safe, der Hedy.
Guck mal, was wir...
Unzerstörbar, unzerstörbar.
100 HP noch.
Wie kann man das eigentlich sehen?
Das ist so bald, wenn der fast leer ist.
Das ist 100 HP.
Da hoch, dann gewinnen wir das Spiel.
Ja, lass kurz da hoch stoppen.
Da liegen wahrscheinlich schon welche.
Ja, egal. Die werden es nicht kommen sehen.
Die fliegen halt mit dem Hedy rauf.
Die werden es nicht kommen sehen.
Ey, also wenn die hier liegen, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ist normal.
Die liegt da immer.
Ich mach den Hedy weg.
Ich hab keine Ammo mehr.
Wer hat von uns die Ammo Box?
Ja, ich. Die Hedy.
Die Hedy hat die Ammo Box.
Fuck.
So.
Warum leben da noch 34?
Die können sich jetzt aber schön alle weghexen.
Was?
Alter.
Ja, ja.
Also.
30 Gegner noch.
Alter, was ist denn da los?
Die haben die Runde in der Ecke gelegen.
Ey, voll stabil eigentlich die Runde.
Voll gut.
Guck mal, ich hab so viel Schaf.
Warum ist es hier eigentlich kalt?
Aber auch kein Hedy.
Äh, okay.
Nimm mal die Markierung bitte weg da.
Okay.
Die lila.
Wait never mind.
Holy.
Okay, ich mach mal Lagerfeuer an.
Hat jemand einen Ammo Box?
Die Lagerfeuer.
Für unser Camp.
Die kommen da grad so raus mit dem letzten H überlebend.
Und du fragst, ob jemand einen Ammo Box dabei hat.
Ja, darf man doch fragen?
Nein.
Warum hat der die dann nicht schneller?
Wir haben die nicht dabei.
Nox2702, Dankeschön.
Subscription, high IQ.
Chat geht heute wieder richtig steil.
So.
Muss was baschen.
Ja, solche Freunde, die brauchen keine Scheiße.
It's a team play, we don't know yet.
Cedric, leg ihn auch mal eine Platte.
Wie, Brox, Dankeschön.
Nein.
Hier vor dir.
Niemand schaut mir zu.
Niemand mag mich.
Niemand kauft mich.
Und niemand tropft mir Sachen.
Wie niemand kauft dich?
Wir haben das Geld zusammengelegt.
Wir sollten jetzt nicht so sehr hier die ganze Zeit nur am Rand rumgammeln.
Wir wissen, wie das endet.
Ja, wir stemmen am ersten Team, was man feindet, oder?
Lass mal noch 22 Sekunden warten.
Oder lass dich hierhin pushen.
Okay, moving.
Moritz, was hast du eigentlich für eine Waffe?
Grau und MP.
Machen wir mal deine MP.
Wobei jetzt ist Warten gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich finde Warten gut gerade.
Die müssen alle da unten rein.
Und bei uns kann keiner kommen.
Ja, man.
Da liegt noch voll im Muni.
Hast du schon?
Ja, ich hab cool.
Ich glaube, da pusht jemand zu uns.
Ja, ich komme.
Wo ist Snipe hin?
Ich komme schon.
Der ist hinten am Baum.
Komm mit mir, komm mit mir.
Und wo?
Kann ich dich?
Okay, pass auf, da sind noch welche.
Also, ich weiß nicht wie viele, wie viele waren das?
Zwei?
Alle drei haben auf mich geschossen, deshalb war ich tot.
Close.
Hier vorne einer ausgerastet.
Einer hier ausgerastet.
Wir sind hier unten, bei Lila.
Wo war denn mein S?
Habe einen.
Unten, wir unten noch.
Ah, unten im Bus ist ein Sniper.
Hier unten im Bus.
Einer down.
Da rechts am Bus, da kommt ein Mate rein.
Ich sehe nichts.
Da unten, zwei Stück.
Zwei Stück am Bus.
Einer im Bus, der andere dahinter.
Von rechts, von rechts kriege ich irgendwas ab, ich weiß.
Dann müssen wir wieder hoch auf unsere Halbpose gehen.
Ja, die Halbpose.
Wo liegt noch ein Drop?
Ich gucke mal meine Perps.
Oder habe ich das schon gemacht?
Hier ist noch ein Loot bei mir.
Ja, ich brauche die Platten.
Ich muss mir Geist holen.
Das gibt es nicht.
Kommt ihr mit?
Hier unten waren noch welche.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Hier ist auch noch Muni.
Einer war auf jeden Fall noch.
Wollt ihr nicht da hinkommen mit mir?
Guck mal, da ist ein Drop.
Ja, ich meine ja, deswegen.
Ich brauche...
Am Bus, am Bus, der stirbt gleich.
Am Bus habe ich einen.
Ich sehe absolut nichts, aber ich helfe ihm einfach mal.
Ich gehe mit Modus.
Ich komme auch mit, ich komme auch mit.
Max, ich bin weg bei dir.
Er ist down, er ist down.
Aber er lebt noch, er lebt noch.
Er ist nicht teamwork.
Kommt mit hoch bitte.
Ah, jetzt Eliminated.
Hier, hier.
Geht nach links von dir, geht nach links von dir, Moritz.
Über dir, über dir, über dir.
Schieb weg, schieb weg.
Ja, den habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich habe einen gefinished.
Oh Gott, die campen da richtig auf dem Boden liegen.
Ciao.
Hey, komm, komm, komm.
Da, da oben, da rechts, da rechts.
Max, dein...
Oh mein Gott.
Ich glaube, ich bin safe.
Hast du ihn getötet?
Der pusht, der pusht, der pusht.
Der C4.
Er kommt, er pusht, er pusht, er pusht.
Da oben sind die markiert.
Du Arschloch.
Junge, der hat voll noch in mich rein.
Ich habe einen noch gehabt.
Der andere hat auch gehoben.
Einer links noch, einer links noch.
Bei der markierten Uzi, bei der markierten Uzi.
Oh, der linke Seite, ja, der hat mich getötet.
Der mit dem Schwein, du.
Hast du ihn?
Ja.
Wir wollen dringend, das sind nur platten, der Arsch.
Dieser Amos wäre zu wichtig.
Hier links unten. Hab ich doch.
Und noch eine Maske. Hier unten.
Jawoll. Und da oben ist der andere.
Ich muss ja erstmal einen Gegner kennen.
Nee, wir wissen nicht, wo der ist.
Oh, da würde ich nicht rein.
Wieso, das sind beide Teams, das sind beide Teams.
Ja, lass die doch, sie sind linkszeitig bekämpfen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Zone.
Ihr könnt da noch kurz oben liegen bleiben.
Ja, wir müssen nur gucken, dass da von rechts nichts kommt.
Ich habe einen genau da.
Max, hast du auch keine Platten?
Ich habe nix.
Egal, dann vorsichtig spielen.
Hast du Platten?
Nee, oder?
Da links unten weiter, Max.
Max, Platten, sorry.
Da ist er.
Da vorne.
Rechts ist nix.
Achtung, nur Bingo-Zone.
Shield-Prague.
Wo sind die anderen?
Ich habe den einen nur ausgenommen, da links.
Ganz links auch noch einen, Richtung grün.
An grün.
Der Sniper, Gott, ist am Start.
Anderes rechts.
Da genau am Stein.
Was? Rechts oder gibt es doch nicht rechts?
Da, wo Max jetzt ist.
Hier, zwei Stück, zwei Stück.
Da ist das andere Team.
Heute läuft es aber.
Ach du Heilige.
Er sagt rechts und ist doch nicht rechts.
Es war rechts einer vom Berg, glaube ich.
Und links war auch noch einer.
Da meint er doch nicht rechts, sondern so.
Aber Angriff.
Cowboy-Hut, aber auch voll mit seinem ganzen Leben aufgespielt.
So ein Cowboy-Hut, Alter.
Kann man sich jetzt nicht die Stats angucken von der letzten Runde?
Was ist das denn hier?
Hier ist der Cheater.
Chat, ich habe gehört, das Free-Bundle triggert euch.
Wo sehe ich denn das Free-Bundle?
Ah.
Wo muss ich denn bei Ghost nochmal?
Ah, hier ist Free-Bundle.
Aber wie hieß das ungefähr?
Weiß ich nicht, ich gucke mal kurz.
Guck mal im Stream.
Es lädt, es lädt.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Er heißt...
Sui-Ton.
C-R-K-C-I als Gunpack und dann
S-U-I und dann Ton.
Ja, er hatte nur 10 Kills.
Oh, ist das schlecht.
Ah, 10 Kills haben wir nachher gestorben.
Ich habe alle geslayt, aber es bringt halt nichts, wenn du keinen Cluster hast.
Ja.
Cluster für alle Zeiten und wie länger.
Das war vielleicht doof, die
rechts rum zu pushen und dann haben wir
links quasi aufgegeben und es wurde uns
genommen.
Der letzte.
Einfach ein Zentimeter weiter oben
gewesen.
Dann wäre auch gar nichts mehr gewesen.
Dann wäre Morris sonst mal gefündet gewesen.
Das war richtig gut.
Ja, aber ich habe ihnen ein Sheep rate gegeben.
Und die Pharma ist wirklich die schlechteste
Waffe im ganzen Spiel.
Ja, die suckt einfach ab.
Aber ich habe alles getan.
Ich finde die richtig
gut, also so wie die da.
Mit so einem Mindestvisier.
Sie sind nicht einmal nicht Top 5
geworden.
Die Spiele waren nicht schlecht.
Muss man echt sagen.
Das könnte das erste Mal
Storage schauen für heute sein.
Ja, meinste.
Aber das ist schon recht weit weg.
Das gewagt.
Aber das Flugzeug kriegt
gewagt für alles. Wir können auch nach
Downtown gehen, die dauern keine hin. Also
was machen wir? Wir Storage schauen.
Wir brauchen
so eine Standardstrategie.
Das stimmt schon.
Hast du schon recht.
Da hast du schon recht. Das ist total random.
Hast du Glück.
Nee, Gulag ist kacke.
Ist so krass vercampt immer.
Was hat dich gekillt?
Einer Down.
Hier in der Kiste.
Er ist tot.
Ja, okay.
Brauch noch irgendwas
Scheiß.
Okay.
Ich gucke vor dem Dach.
Auf der anderen Seite
flankt noch einer. Ich bin gleich bei dir.
Sind da noch mehr?
Richtung Schwimmbad.
Hier hinten.
Da hinten ist ein Gegner.
Da sind zwei Stück.
Einer geht hier rein.
Anderer geht links rum.
Wir können die einzeln machen.
Ich habe einen Cluster Strike.
Ich muss aufs Dach.
Wieder nicht auf dieses Dach.
Auf dem Dach. Alle drei auf dem Dach.
Wo kommen die auf einmal her?
Ich kann dir nicht helfen.
Ich habe keine Schuss mehr.
Du kannst überleben.
Hast du noch was?
Nice.
Ich dachte, die sind bei dir drüben.
Aber auf einmal stehen drei Leute vor mir.
Max, gibt es bei dir unten noch irgendwelche Waffen?
Wenn ich dir das Video angucken könnte,
wäre das so geil.
Wir schießen dir was an.
Vom Store aus.
Passt schon.
Komm mal zu mir.
Wir können CD kaufen.
Ich muss weg.
Die sind echt scharf auf mich.
Nimm mit.
Wo?
Die haben Kopfgeld auf.
Ich habe Schild auf dem Rücken.
Ich kriege mich nicht tot.
Jetzt boxen sie mich gleich.
Jetzt boxen sie mich.
Geh hier hin.
Die wissen nicht, wo du wirst.
Letzte Runde für heute Abend.
Dann reicht es.
50 Meter.
Ohne Brille.
Du musst Max zu retten.
Ich gebe alles, was ich habe.
Die Kiste war noch wichtig.
Die Kiste war für eine Pracht.
Der Kloster war gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Der hat die echt zurückgebrannt.
Wir fahren direkt zum Bunker.
Moritz, fahr.
Ich kann nicht.
Du willst einen.
Ach du Scheiße.
Da ist er.
Fahr rückwärts.
Das neue Meter ist rückwärts fahren.
Vorwärts ist overrated.
Der war schon ein Gegner.
Ich hole mir Muni.
Dann können wir weiterfahren.
Ich habe den letzten so gefickt.
Er kommt mit einer MP an.
Ich habe keinen Schild gehabt.
Hinter den Steinen.
Der MG konnte ihn nicht nachladen.
Erst mal den Sniper raus holen.
Und dann hält er dich.
Bitte fahr nicht hier.
Die haben einen Schild.
Wenn ich mir die Stats angucke.
Den hast du richtig gegeben.
Du sollst retten.
Warum ist der Auto kaputt?
Der hat aufs Auto geschossen.
Beide.
Ich fange mal ein Kickart hoch.
Ich fange und gehe zum Bunker.
Ich gehe mal weg.
Mo, lass mal das Geld zusammenlegen.
Ich brauche einen Plattenhoch.
Hediotopper auf dem Weg zu euch.
Mo, wo ist das Gelbe?
Wo ist der Topper?
Warum kann der Duta nicht hoch?
Immer noch da wo ich mich kenne.
Wie kommt man hier aufs Dach?
Hier.
Max, drop mal Money bitte.
Weil Moritz Money ist unter die Map geflogen.
Was geht da?
Ich komme.
Ich habe auch keine Plattenhoch.
Ich weiß.
Einer hat keine.
Ich würde nach Rockets fragen.
Ich habe mir selber Raketenhörer.
Gib Moritz mal die eine.
Ich bin auf dem Weg.
Wo geht der oben?
Ich sehe nicht wo.
Der ist tot.
Wo ist der?
Der ist mit mir drin.
Was?
Man wird auch rein RPG'd.
Hast du rein RPG'd?
Ich habe gerade rein RPG'd.
Weil ich jetzt auch mal das mache.
Der hat mich angeschnichten.
Hab schon los.
Wie kann der da neben euch
in das Haus reinlaufen?
Der wird angeschnitten.
Ich hasse ihn.
Das ist ja richtig für Noobs.
Ich hasse mein Leben.
Lass mal lieber weiterlaufen.
Wir müssen doch zum Job machen.
Ihr kommt nicht mehr in den Bunker.
Vergesst nicht, die Zone ist gleich im Bunker.
Die Zone ist auch im anderen Bunker.
Und Loco mal Loco.
Wir haben zwei Kikards und Penns.
Bleifrei geht heute eigentlich.
4 Wins von 9 Spielen oder so.
Ich kaufe mir bald 360 Grad Kamera
für dieses Spiel.
Dass ich auch hinter mir gucken muss.
Da trete ich immer so.
Ich muss meine Brille echt putzen.
Wenn ich jetzt down gehe beim Drop holen,
dann quitte ich.
Du hast gerade von hinten gesnippert.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich weiß, dass das Max war.
Willst du den haben im Bogen?
Ja, ich habe sonst schon Raketenwürfe.
Hier, da liegt er.
Nee, ich nicht.
Alles gut.
Da kann auch ein Bunker rein.
Ja, lass mal.
Vielleicht ein bisschen für Money halt.
Aber wir müssen das
Vollgas machen und einer muss den
Laster bereit halten bitte.
Ich brauche schon einen im Bunker.
Ach, da ist ein Bunker.
Wollen wir nicht lieber zu dem fahren?
Dann haben wir mehr Zeit.
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Aber die Zone wird relativ langsam sein.
Der Drop kommt jetzt.
Warum fährt keiner von euch mit dem scheiß Auto?
Da war kein Auto.
Voll diesen schnellen Heizer.
Ach Gott, das ist vorbei, weil die Steine so lang sind.
Nee, ich machs.
Einer muss unten rechts warten.
Ein Auto ready.
Wo du dagegen klaffst, dann gehts schneller.
Ich hasse euch, dass ihr alle so
Lootguy seid wie ich.
Da ist schon ein Viererteam drin.
Ich mach den niemals direkt den nächsten auf.
Ich mach das schrecklich.
Aber die Zone kommt.
Die Tür geht auf.
Eine Platte, ich fass es nicht.
Geht nicht auf.
Wieso?
Geht doch mit der zweiten.
Nee, nee, nee. In Season 4 kommt das wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin da rausgelaufen ohne ein einziges Magazin.
Ah, der Schuss.
Ich hab ne Moneybox mit.
Ich hab noch keinen.
Wofür hab ich ne Keycard?
Weiß nicht.
Ich hab auch ne Kreditkarte, wenn du sie kaufen würdest.
Nichts wie weg hier.
Er hat auch ne Kreditkarte,
wenn du sie kaufen würdest.
Eigentlich ist es ähnlich.
Ich hab ne Kreditkarte.
Oha.
Einmalig die Bogenspieler.
Da hinten liegt ne Moneybox.
Da hinten.
Da hinten ist noch das andere Bunker.
Lass da hin.
Das war es das eigentlich.
Also wir sollten uns ein paar
UAVs und Zeug kaufen.
Bunker, Bunker, Bunker, Bunker.
Ist das dein Ernst?
Bist du der offene, der mir von gebrannt?
Ach was?
Okay Vollgas gucken.
Dagegenschlagen.
Wir schaffen das nicht, wir schaffen das nicht.
Nein, guck mal.
Wir können das nicht mehr raus.
Fahr, fahr, fahr.
Ich geb nicht gegen den Panzer.
Ist das so unglaublich?
Kommt raus, die Zone ist schon im Bunker am Anfang.
Ja, fahr, fahr.
Ich hab keine Gasmaske, ich sterbe.
Wir sind so doof.
Aber es reicht.
Es reicht, es reicht.
Oh, ihr fahrt einfach ohne uns weg.
Nein, ich sterbe, wenn ihr wegfahrt.
Das hätte noch locker gereicht.
Mach spring ran, spring ran.
Mach spring ran.
Gehfffffff...
Der Antimates ist nicht likelihoodlich in Zone.
Moritz, ihr hattet eine Gasmaske, ich hatte keine.
Ich hatte auch keine.
Das ist egal.
Teamplay, wir müssen Mal uns kaufen.
Aber wir haben...
Ja, Junge, ich glaub's dir gar nicht.
Es hält du mich sicher, weil der Agavator länger...
Ich kauf dich gleich bei der nächsten...
Wo geh mal hin zum Kaufen.
Kaufen.
Nirgends.
Müssen wir da runter?
Ja.
Irgendwo müssen wir Moritz kaufen.
Wir müssen Moritz kaufen?
Ja, dann halbieren, dann sehen wir.
Genau.
Wir müssen Moritz kaufen.
Kannst du mal kurz die Chat-Abstimmung starten, ob du sie richtig schaltest?
Strawpool mach ich auf, Paul.
Wir müssen Moritz kaufen.
Wir müssen Moritz nicht kaufen, geh da weg.
Hier im Dorf drin.
Hier im Dorf.
Ja, im Dorf.
Hey, bei mir ist der raus, oder wo?
Ja, ich aber sind hier unten.
Da ist einer unter mir!
Ich bin doch schon da.
Ich bin schon da.
Dann durchaus habe ich sicher Porsche gekleidet.
Ja, genau.
Warte, a!
Ah, meine Güte.
Einer hat Armorbreak.
Der soll sich nur übernehmen.
Wollt ihr mich überhaupt kaufen, wenn ich Cooler-Cup?
Na ja, du sagst ja nicht mal, dass du Cooler-Cup, du sagst das.
Wo du es kaufst, ist es zurück uns.
Ja, genau.
Und man nimmt so viel Yale.
Ja, die sind jetzt mega reich, die Typen hier, die kaufen sich jetzt alles.
Jett, wir gucken gleich noch mal eine halbe Stunde oder so ein bisschen Videos oder sowas.
Da ich dann in Ruhe pennen kann.
Ne, und?
Jetzt kauf uns noch mal zurück Max.
Lass aufklatschen, ohne willst du, lass aufklatschen.
Null Dollar, das ist ja der perfekte Startpunkt.
Ah, Beatbro und wir gucken gleich noch mal ein bisschen Kram, da ich dann pennen kann.
Wir sind jetzt fertig, also zu gut wie.
Mal gucken, was da noch geht, ich glaube ja nicht, dass allzu viel noch geht.
Kann ich die Kategorie schon mal umstellen?
Monarch S, just chat chatting, nix, nix, bester Titel.
So, jetzt müsste ich die Kategorie gleich umstellen, wie gesagt letzte Runde hier.
Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen? Gibt es irgendwelche Technikgeschichten oder so?
Die wir noch besprechen, müssen heute.
Also wie gesagt, dass es den neuen Raspberry Pi mit 8GB gibt, habe ich gesehen.
Ich sehe halt überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Ähm, es war ansonsten auch so.
War sonst noch irgendwas spannendes die letzten Tage technikmäßig?
Die letzten Tage waren eher geprägt durch irgendwelche politischen Sachen.
Vor allem, dass auf Twitter mal wieder jeder zu den Geschichten in den USA seine Weltanschauung kundtun muss.
Und sich besser finden muss, als die anderen letzten Tage angesagt.
Ich mach da nicht mit, ich schreib dazu nix, weil im Prinzip, was du schreibst, ist eigentlich eh verkehrt.
Ähm, Anonymus Hack. Ja, aber das ist auch nicht so interessant, ich mein so komisch ist so ein Radio.
Wir halt nur so. Alter, der rettet uns jetzt echt noch, oder?
Ja, ich denk mir halt so ein Radio Hack, man, das ist ja nicht so, dass man da wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig viel Hacks on muss, oder?
Die Dinger sind doch eh zum größten Teil offen wie Scheunentore.
Stelle ich mir zumindest so vor, dass die da nicht so viele Security-Leute am Start haben, dass das halbwegs sicher ist.
Vor allem, warum so eine Radiostation überhaupt im Netz sein muss, ist mal fragwürdig, aber okay.
Sony Event verschoben, echt?
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Warum das denn?
Warum das denn? Warum das denn?
Wo war das denn? Ist das nicht in Japan, das Sony Event?
Oh fuck, ich werde auch noch gerätzt.
Ich lade, ich lade, ich lade.
Ich hab jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich hier noch mal gerätzt werde, Alter.
Hock, du hattest wirklich gerätzt, Alter. Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich hab sogar die Stream-Kategorie schon umgestellt, weil ich nicht mehr beliebt hab, Alter.
Nee, heut nicht mehr.
Ach, guck mal da, ne Farmas.
Nee, ne Odin, ne Odin.
Reicht, ne, das reicht, echt.
Also Chat, ihr könnt euch ja gleich schon mal überlegen, was wir gleich machen, wenn die Runde vorbei ist.
Wird ja höchstens nur noch 5 Minuten dauern, viel länger kann es ja nicht mal gehen.
Alter, was ist denn das letzte Leben?
Ist hier irgendwas drinne noch?
Wahrscheinlich Gegner, aber wir werden es auch wieder.
Oh, Unglut.
Was ist das hier?
Oder Ultra-Cheater.
Oh, ne Farmas, geil.
Ja, endlich.
Die Waffe, die jeder will.
Hallo?
Leichtes Maschinengewehr, das ist gut.
Ich kommentier's wie Z3-Flute.
Ist sie zu langsam oder was?
Ich glaub, ich nehm mich mit.
Das Z3 findet nichts.
Doch, oben irgendwas.
Nee, hier oben ist nix mehr.
Wir sichern hier.
Wer?
Elf.
Mein 100 zum Besten.
Da oben, oben.
Komm, welche?
Kira, Kira da, nicht bewegen.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt seh ich.
Oh, ich hab.
Ja, jipp.
So, dann hol ich jetzt den Drop-Trusch und dann hol ich.
Ja.
Du bist auch dumm.
Das reicht.
Das reicht für mich.
Okay, okay, okay.
Was zum Teufel?
Was ist los, Alter?
Ich krieg von allen Seiten.
Dann versteck dich irgendwo.
Der Schuss.
Ich hab ihn.
Links auf dem Haus.
Wir gehen hinten raus.
Ja, ja.
Versteck mich, versteck mich.
Hier kannst du noch looten.
Wie mich looten?
Kiste.
Na, top.
Wo waren sie denn?
Oben drauf.
Keine Ahnung.
Und er zählt wieder mich oder will mich erzielen.
Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Jemand dreht.
Ich dachte, du hast den schon.
Ich dachte, du hast.
Das ist ja witzig, wenn man echt so stirbt, weil die Mates das nicht rafigen.
Junge, aber dass er mich da noch gesnitert hat im letzten Ding, weißt du?
Ja.
Ähm, ich will das mit meinem, ich will Loot von mir haben.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, war der auf dem Dach bargelb oder wo war der denn?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber da kommt ein Druck.
Ein Auto.
Wie ist der da drauf?
PC, PC, abhauen, abhauen, abhauen.
Ich sehe, ich laufe jetzt, ich mach's einfach, ich mach's.
Wir müssen, wir müssen es zum Schaffen.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das Loadout ist schon bereit.
Passt doch, super.
Rechts oben, rechts oben.
Aber da ist nix, da ist nix.
Ja, lass mal zum Schaffen, lass mal zum Schaffen.
Und dahinter ist der Truck.
Teddy, hau den, hau doch den LKW weg.
Drop, drop hier euer Geld, drop hier euer Geld.
Ja, hier.
Hier links auf dem Weg.
Truck, Teddy, dein Rückenpläne, den hol ich mir glaub ich.
Man wird, ich komm eh nicht wieder.
Sollen wir das Hospital hoch oder runter?
Soll ich oben drauf landen und die Runde gewinnen?
So, mach mal.
Mit der Pistol, mach.
Hat vorher auch schon gelöst.
Pack.
Platten, Platten.
Hier, da.
Ich hab drei Stück.
Genau, das ist ein Gegner.
Teddy nimmt eine.
Ui, das ist ein Gegner.
Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten.
Teddy, rett mal.
Ich retz' ihn, ich retz' ihn.
Einmal break, einmal break.
Okay, Alter, jetzt war ich vorbei.
Okay, Leute.
Ja, okay.
Reicht für heute.
Wir hatten ein paar echt leise Runden dabei.
Anstrengend.
Anstrengend, ja, wie sau.
Huge anstrengend.
Ja, bis morgen oder so.
Mal gucken.
Tschüss.
So, Chet.
Wir haben's geschafft.
Anstrengend, ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss was essen.
Ich hab noch nichts gegessen heute Abend.
Ich mach das jetzt mal nebenbei.
Sesambrötchen.
Immer diese Schwitze, aber hardcore.
Hier ist auch scheiß warm drin.
Ich mach mal die Klimaanlage an.
Die Klimaanlage muss sein.
Hier ist übelst warm drin.
Weil ich so geschwitzt hab in dem Spiel wieder.
Excellent.
Gut, Chet.
Was gab's denn jetzt Wichtiges die letzten Tage,
wo ich meinen Senf aus technischer Natur
noch nicht dazu gegeben hab?
Ähm.
Ich hab mir noch ein paar Sachen
aus der Technik aus der Technik
aus der Technik aus der Technik aus der Technik
aus der Technik aus der Methodooo.
Doch das wird heute erst wieder.
Ähm.
Ich hab mir das Docking-Manöver angeguckt,
das war un spektakulär langweilig.
Hab ich mir aber schon gedacht.
Solche Sachen sind nie sonderlich spannend.
Ich meins fliegt halt aufeinander zu
und dockt an.
Das war jetzt eher...
So.
Ansonsten
Neuer BDO-Spat. Stimmt, warum steht Game überhaupt noch auf Black Desert, Alter? MonkaS
Weiß gar nicht, was mit den Leuten immer los ist. Warum sind alle so scharf auf rein
grafische Engine-Vergleiche? Also ich würde mal behaupten, außer für Kenner, der jeweiligen
Engine, ist es fast nicht zu merken, so richtig in welchem Spiel, also außer für so ein fertiger Asset-Flip, aber
welche Engine im Spiel gebastelt ist. Für mich war viel wichtiger, welche Programmiersprache, also sprich
welche kann ich, welche, wo liegt mir, Tools und alles. Die reine Grafikvergleiche sind doch eigentlich total unspektakulär.
Zibelung schreibt, ich habe heute mal meinen fest verbauten ESP32 mit deinem Update-Code versehen.
Oh geil, da läuft ja bei dir ein ESP32 mit Code von mir, der noch nicht mal bei mir läuft.
Sorry, falls ich kurz laut verabschluss. Kann mich schon gar niemand dran erinnern.
This is the end of Black Ops 2, rest in peace. Ja, das haben wir doch schon gesehen, die ganzen Spin-Bots sind wieder am Start.
Bacon-Pig-Dogs in Planket, excellent, Kokona. Wisst ihr, was mir viel lieber wäre, wenn dieser
Hashtag auf Twitter, auf Twitter ist ja aktuell hier, USA is burning, Hashtag, wo auch immer,
wie alle Seiten hier wieder so drauf abgehen, sich zu profilieren mit dem Kram, was in den USA abgeht.
Also USA is burning hat heute Morgen getrennt, mir wäre es viel lieber, wäre es in diesem Hashtag
auch ein neues BBQ Pit-Boy-Video gegangen. Wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns nochmal das ändern, ich muss mal kurz in mein Brötchen reinbeißen heute.
Die sehen aber zur Abwechslung richtig gut aus, mit richtig ordentlichem, ordentlichem Foto am Ende.
Den wünschen wir jetzt auch reinhauen, den Bacon-Pig-Dogs in Planket.
Gut, davon war er auszugehen. YouTube-Kacke, Bibi im Krankenhaus, okay.
In Deutschland sind Frauen bei der Geburt ihres ersten Kindes im Durchschnitt neuneinhalb Jahre alt, Tendenz steigend.
In der Gynäkologie der Klinik am Südring trifft jetzt eine 17-jährige ein, die völlig unverhofft
schwanger geworden ist. Schwester Mira erwartet eine Schülerin, die von der Notaufnahme auf die
Kinderstation überwiesen wurde. Das Mädchen hat schlimme Bauchschmerzen und kann kaum noch
aufrecht stehen. Ihr Freund begleitet sie. Die Patientin, die ich vorgefunden habe.
Das ist diesmal aber nicht so lustig wie die anderen YouTube-Kacke-Videos.
Guck mal, es gibt noch ein Elektro-Boom-Video. Bacon-Bomb. Verbinden C+. Oh, das ist was für mich, glaube ich.
Aber das ist 30 Minuten lang, das kann ich mir nicht jetzt angucken.
Moment, was? Eine Schleife 0 bis 20, bzw. 19. Wenn random Modulo 10, was davon größer ist,
aha, na gut, was auch immer. Stimmt, Sony Twitter. Wo hat Sony das geschrieben,
damit das es verschoben wird? Playstation wahrscheinlich, ne? Okay, wo steht?
Steht hier nicht. Sony Pressekonferenz verschoben. Wo hat denn das her?
Oben? Ah, ich hab da schon wieder komplett rübergescrollt.
Ja, kann ich aus Sony Sicht auch verstehen, dass jetzt vielleicht wirklich keine günstige Zeit,
aber wobei ich halt für mich persönlich sagen muss, gerade jetzt, ich mein, überall, überall ist hier voll,
wenn ich das schon sehe, Rassismus gegen Weiße, Vorzitonisch, What about-ism, Extremisten, Solidarität.
Ja, mach Gaming-Zeug. Mach Gaming-Zeug, Alter, dann lenkt es ein wenigstens von dem restlichen Kram ab,
der da grad am Start ist.
Big Prime.
Das könnte natürlich auch sein, dass die gerade einfach nicht bereit sind dafür.
Ist ja auch keinerlei Micro da.
Keinerlei Micro am Start, Alter.
Get schreckt.
Was denn das? Super Mario Bros. PC-Port. PC-Port ist immer so eine Sache, die Dinger werden nie fertig.
Emulator. Emulator, ähm, mit gemordeter Emulator ist immer besser. Also eigentlich ja nicht,
aber diese Linie hier geht mir voll auf den Keks.
Irgendwelche Remakes werden nie fertig.
Wo gibt's den Download? Wo gibt's den Download? Nirgendwo. Also wird das nie fertig.
Wie fändest du es, wenn es ein Battlefield 3 Remaster geben würde? Sehr einfallslos, ehrlich gesagt.
Battlefield 3 war zu seiner Zeit gut und für mich immer noch, ich sparsche zur Zeit, die ich in Battlefield hatte.
Aber ich will eigentlich ehrlich gesagt kein Remake von Battlefield 3. Die sollen ein neues, gutes
Battlefield machen. Da können die auch gerne einen Service-Game draus machen, wenn es gut ist.
Das muss von Anfang an gut sein und das muss mich von Anfang an halten.
Ich hätte mir damals gewünscht, dass Battlefield 3 ein Service-Game ist, ohne dass ich wusste,
dass der Kram Service-Game überhaupt heißt.
Wie geil wäre es gewesen, einfach vier Jahre, vier Jahre oder zwei, drei, vier Jahre aktuelles,
so wie bei Rainbow Six, so aktuelles Battlefield 3 zu haben, mit neuem Content, mit neuem Scheiß,
wäre doch top gewesen.
Es ist eine ganz neue 얘기.
man sieht so gut wie kein level man sieht nur schloss das wird doch unreal engine das
wird nie fertig das ist immer so fail ich finde die dinger ich finde diese ganzen zelda 64
mario 64 dinger wo einer was zusammenklickt ich meine es ist ja nicht so als wäre das
super schwierig im unreal level editor peach schloss nachzubauen ehrlich leute ich hab noch
nie was mit unreal gemacht ja aber peach schloss nachzubauen traue ich mir auch zu was natürlich
was anderes wäre wenn man das movemen und so alles selbst programmieren würde aber das
gibt es wahrscheinlich auch schon fix und fertig ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal da ist nichts
großartiges dabei wikipedia speedruns
warum gibt es wikipedia speedruns
das muss ich mir jetzt angucken was zum teufel ist ein wikipedia speedrun
alter youtube kriegt doch mal euren scheiß zusammen auf der seite
romandro gute frage er fragt wie heißt der all you can eat asiate wo ich mit dem kabum
in frankfurt manchmal war das da
wie die zombie map
ah jetzt heißt wang fu haben anscheinend die eigentümer gewechselt und die bewertungen
sind auch nicht mehr so gut
das war nämlich richtig nice
ja ein ordentlich großes buffet am start
ambiente war auch cool
ordentlich großes buffet am start
seht ihr jede menge zeugs
eigentlich somit das größte china buffet was ich so in frankfurt kenne
weil ich schon ordentlich ja
und
Ja, das ist eine tolle Idee. Wir machen einen oder zwei Praktika.
Einmal Races, okay? Willst du Subbetten auf das oder willst du das nur für Spaß machen?
Ich finde total gute Subbetten. Wir können mit 5 anfangen und sehen, wo es geht.
Das klingt perfekt für mich. Lass uns mit einem Praktika-Race anfangen.
Für den Praktika willst du an Ant starten und Crowe enden?
Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee. Okay, 3, 2, 1, los. Wir gehen jetzt an Crowe.
Ich denke, dass wir Crowe finden müssen. Ich will Pflanzen, ich will Insekten.
Ich habe etwas gegessen und dachte, vielleicht sind sie mit Pferden gegessen.
Wie wäre es mit Steuerung F? Und nach Crowe suchen?
Ich suche Pflanzen. Pflanzen, Pflanzen, Pflanzen, Pflanzen, Pflanzen, Crowe. Wir brauchen Crowe.
Bibel? Vielleicht sind Pflanzen in der Bibel. Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, die Bibel verbindet vieles.
Crowe, Crowe, Crowe, Crowe-Familie. Wo? Okay, Pflanzen, Pflanzen, Pflanzen. Okay, fertig.
Was? Ich suchte die Bibel. Mein Gott. Okay, das war...
Das ist nicht ein totaler Schwachsinn. Ein totaler Schwachsinn, aber irgendwie lustig.
24 Minuten gucke ich meine Schale.
Drei. Komm schon, wo ist die Bibel? Es muss hier sein.
Standard PMR Polymorphic Educator. Ah ja, exzellent. C++, alles klar.
Ich will es eigentlich gar nicht wissen. Das ist so eine abgedrehte Sprache.
Ja, bei mir ist es halt heimland, weil wir haben das oft im Hintergrund an.
Die 299 Pfund Alie Espresso Maschine. Es gibt wenig, was mich noch weniger interessieren könnte.
Ich habe Durst. Ich habe Dorscht, wie man so schön in Hessen sagt. Dorscht.
Sagt man an anderen Teilen von Deutschland. Ich sage Dorscht.
So, Chat, was machen wir jetzt? Wir haben noch 10 Minuten Zeit,
können wir Big Brain Sachen machen. Oder vielleicht 20 Minuten mal gucken.
Sag mal, habe ich meine?
Ich habe gerade gedacht, ich habe meine Klimaanlage aus. Wir sind auf Wärme stehen.
Hier drin ist so krass warm. Der war gut. Also, was auch immer das sein soll.
Die Seite mache ich nicht auf. Klingt nicht so vertrauenserweckend.
Aber 50 Minuten kann ich nicht mehr angucken. In Geografie bin ich echt schlecht.
In sowas bin ich schlecht. Das kann ich. Ich muss da näher ranzoomen.
Das ist Deutschland und Österreich ist dann das da.
Ich habe mich um eins verklickt. Wo ist Haiti? Hier irgendwo, oder?
Da? Karibik? Kann man da irgendeine Hilfe?
Das ist im Leben nicht Haiti. Das ist Paraguay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo Haiti liegt. Wahrscheinlich eher hier.
So eine kleine Furzinsel. Was?
Da wäre Haiti gewesen. Niederlande?
Da? Die sind doch hier auch irgendwo nebendran.
Die sind doch da irgendwo. Die müssen doch hier irgendwo sein.
Das ist die Türkei. Ach da?
Nee. Da habe ich doch hingeklickt eben schon.
Da habe ich doch eben schon hingeklickt. Was?
Was? Keine Ahnung.
Das ist ein dummes Quiz. Kann ich hier einen Technik-Quiz machen?
Da kann ich nichts mithalten. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, dass es existiert.
Also, Saint Vincent and... Okay, wo ist das?
Aha, Karibik. Lichtenstein. Lichtenstein kenne ich.
Lichtenstein ist auch hier irgendwo. Da? Nein, das ist die Schweiz.
Aber die Schweiz ist in der Nähe. Da?
Ach ey, scheiß Geografie-Quiz. Das kann doch keiner.
Wie soll man auf der Map Lichtenstein treffen? Das frage ich mich auch.
Okay, wo ist das? Ich erkenne noch nicht mal das Kontinent.
Ist das Südamerika? Das heißt, es ist irgendwo in der Karibik?
Da? Jetzt ernsthaft?
Das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein. Wer weiß denn sowas?
Die neue Google-Earth sieht richtig gut aus.
Das neue Google-Earth-Prom, ja, genau. Auf Lade, exzellent.
Ja, weiter. Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wo das ist.
Ja, ist gut. Alter. Es ruckelt übrigens, by the way.
Skip. Oh, Hi-Rez. Warum ruckelt denn das so?
Also ich will zu St. Vincent and the Cranadines. Warum ruckelt denn das so?
Ich glaube, ich weiß, warum das ruckelt. Ich muss das im echten Chrome aufmachen.
Das ruckelt es bestimmt nicht. Passt auf, echter Chrome, geht ab.
Okay, echter Chrome, kein Problem. Okay, das da ist St. Vincent und die Cranadines.
Was muss eigentlich die Gründer von einem Land reiten, dass sie sich St. Vincent und
die Cranadines nennen? Okay, das war irgendein Kolonial-Ding, wenn
ich mir die Namen hier angucke. Belmont, Richmond, irgendwas Farm, Port Elizabeth,
das war irgendein, ja, auf jeden Fall. Okay, wo ist die Hauptstadt?
Das da unten gehört auch noch dazu. Wo ist die Hauptstadt?
Ach, das da oben. Das da oben gehört auch noch dabei.
Kingstown, excellent. Okay, das ist ungefähr so groß wie mein
Tal. Alles klar, Chat, jetzt haben wir es auch mal
gesehen. 3D.
Oh, hier gibt es kein 3D. Was soll denn das?
Oh, doch, guck mal hier. Die Good News Bible Church.
Excellent, excellent, was die alles haben. Da ist er hier, der heilige Vincent.
Hier, da ist er, genau da. Ah, der Chat, der Chat ist wieder am Start.
Also, der Chat erklärt uns, dass Christoph Kolumbus sichtete die Insel am 22. Januar
1498, dem Tag des heiligen Vincents von Valencia, nachdem er sie benannte.
Ah, Big Brain Chat. Ich meine, zwar Wikipedia, Copy-Paste, ist
mir auch klar, aber immerhin schneller Wikipedia Copy-Paste.
Und sonst so, Chat. So geil, eine Million, das ist das, was
Deutschland interessiert. Ob wem als Döner in Buchsehude schmeckt.
Oh, jawoll, da machen wir mit, Chat. Also, Chat, wir bleiben wach und gucken zehn
Stunden Ayaya Intensiv Files, oder? Und jetzt ist das hier Baro nicht da.
Alter, ich bin schon nach, ich bin schon nach zehn Sekunden bin ich schon raus.
Ich halte es nicht länger als zehn Sekunden aus.
Ah, ja, ja. Oh, das ist ein geiles Video.
Also, das ist uralt. Ähm, das ist, da hat Caldo mal einen Koreanischen
Klopp, WarCraft, StarCraft. Pro aufgenommen, wie er LPMt.
Das ist so geil, das ist so geil. Und am geilsten ist, dass er manchmal die
Maus loslässt. Ähm, ok, StarCraft, StarCraft, äh, zwei,
hm? Dass er manchmal sogar die Maus loslässt
und dann auf der Tastatur tippt, dass er schneller tippen kann.
Actions per Minute ist LPM. Alles klar, oder?
So hart. Ist eigentlich, Moment, Moment, mal kurz
unterbrechen. Ist eigentlich mal ein Monitor lieferbar
mittlerweile. Jetzt Vorbestellung, ja, habe ich ja gemacht.
Exzellent Vorbestellung habe ich gemacht. Es ist Feiertag, ja, aber trotzdem, vielleicht
ist das ja eingetroffen letzte Woche. Warum nur Full HD?
Weil 240Hz. Das ist die Koreaner, die sind echt unmenschlich
bei sowas. Set Pudding, vier Monate.
Eigentlich schön. Äh, kennst du eigentlich Interhistoryen
auf YouTube? Ja, klar.
Haben wir sogar schon ein paar Videos von geguckt.
Wie der abgeht. 120 gibt es auch als 144.
Äh, nee, und wenn überhaupt dann ultra teuer. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es das gibt.
Die Seite sieht ja sehr vertrauenserwürdig aus.
Also gibt es anscheinend schon, aber wie ich gesagt habe, ultra teuer.
Schauen wir mal. Nö, geht doch, kostet auch nicht viel mehr
als meiner. Aber 27 Zoll ist mir zu groß.
27 Zoll ist mir zu groß. Für mich ist es optimal.
Für mich sind die 25 Zoll 1080p optimal. 25 Zoll ist eine super Größe für 1080p und
1440p musst du eh auf 1080p herunter stellen, wenn du das für 240Hz spielen willst.
Du wirst ja kein Rechner zusammenbauen können, der 1440p macht und dann in den Games auch
die 240Hz gescheit. Also außer in CS vielleicht.
CS läuft ja nur wirklich auf Drucker mit 100FPS. Ja und außerdem habe ich eh, genau, das
kommt, Finny, das kommt dabei. Die meisten Spiele habe ich eh auf Low.
Und CS ist wieder was anderes. CS spielen die meisten ja auf 800x600 und
so was. Letztes Mal wieder von Scream gesehen die
Stats 800x600 mit Black Bars. Kulte Sachs klingt irgendwie sehr, äh, ich
habe kein Franzosen Emote. Sehr französisch. Baguette, genau. Wir brauchen aber unbedingt
meinen Franzosen Emote. Es gibt so viel Stuss auf YouTube.
Ach, das Qualcomm. Was für Videos, was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Ok, verstopfte Ablauf hat 2,5 Millionen Views. Fast so gut wie mal ein Schneevideo.
The first time I did it, if you saw that it was really jammed with dirt and stuff, this
time I'm figuring it's just like leaves, cause if you look up this hill right here, there's
a whole bunch of leaves and debris that's sitting there.
Und jetzt ist der ganze Scheiß in der Kanalisation drinne, da freuen sich die Leute, die den
Kanal reinigen müssen, bestimmt wahnsinnig.
Da freuen sich die Leute, den Kanal sauber machen müssen, bestimmt wahnsinnig jetzt.
Du bist ja ein richtiger Bigbrainer, weißt, wie so ein Gulli-Duckel funktioniert.
Excellent.
Und wenn er das ein paar Mal macht, ist der Kanal verstopft, auch geil.
Was ist Postscriptum?
Ja, ich weiß, dass ein schwarzer Strich durch die Aufnahme durchgeht.
Das liegt daran, weil das ein Bug ist aktuell in Chromium, wenn du danach suchst, findest
du auch recht viel.
Und das betrifft nur, wenn man Pech hat, die falsche Vergrößerungsstufe für den Browser
eingestellt zu haben, ansonsten ist es weg.
Guckt hier, also, zeig's euch, seht ihr hier, hier sieht man es gut, der schwarze Strich
hier und sobald ich die, jetzt ist er weg, jetzt ist er wieder da, jetzt ist er wieder
weg.
Es ist nicht Pech, dass ich genau die falsche Vergrößerungsstufe eingestellt habe.
Also wenn du einfach eins runterstellst, ist er wieder weg, aber ich habe ja absichtlich
genau diese Vergrößerungsstufe, dass nur das Video da ist, dass ich den ganzen anderen
Shit nicht sehen muss.
Das ist eine richtig geile Verarsche, vor allem auch die Mikrofonqualität.
Das ist richtig gut.
Was am besten, wisst ihr was mir in Tutorials immer voll auf den Sack geht, was mich richtig
triggert in Tutorials, wenn dann irgendwie einer sagt so ja, this is a function of a class
and now you get new functions of a class and you see that it obviously works and it is
obviously faster, dieses Wort obviously geht mir in Tutorials so auf den Sack, ich gucke
dieses Tutorial, weil ich keine Ahnung davon habe und die meisten Sachen sind da nicht
obviously, also offensichtlich, wenn man keine Ahnung hat.
An englischen Sprachen gibt es so ein paar, so zwei, drei Sachen, die mich triggern.
Also das ist einmal, wenn die Leute laufen sagen, dass was obviously ist, so nach dem
Motto, ich hau dir auf die Fresse, it hurts obviously oder vor allem halt ein paar Dinge,
die nicht offensichtlich sind, genau das Falcon fast actually ist auch so eins, was mich auch
nervt ist die Leute, die immer sagen literally oder actually, so nach dem Motto wörtliche,
oh Gott, das ist so schlimm, du hast Leute, die haben so literally, das haben die so voll
in ihren Sprachgebrauch schon aufgenommen, das geht mir so auf den Sack, aber ich glaube,
dass an diesem Punkt ist man erst angelangt, wenn man recht, soll ich sagen, recht gut
die Sachen versteht, weil ansonsten ist man so damit beschäftigt, quasi auf den Inhalt
zu konzentrieren, dass einem so quasi diese Rede wenn gar nicht auffallen, aber Technik,
ich gucke ja fast alles nur noch auf Englisch, ich meine ich bin jetzt nicht der super krasse
flüssige Englisch-Speaker, aber bei mir fehlt es einfach total an der Praxis, paar Tage
Games kommen oder wenn man paar Tage Leute auf der Arbeit hat, die nur Englisch können,
dann geht es immer halbwegs, aber ich verstehe den Kram halt mittlerweile fast alles, ich
meine ich kann jetzt nicht unbedingt Shakespeare lesen, aber das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn
wir im Deutsch Goethe lesen, dann denkst du dir, oh der Schiller, oder was auch sonst
der alles haben, dann denkst du dir auch teilweise, ah ja alles klar, Johan, alles klar, ist klar,
da blickst du auch nicht durch, und so geht es ja Leuten, die Englisch können auch bei
Shakespeare oder was sonst auch alles haben, oder den Franzosen bei Louis Vuitton, ne Quatsch,
wie hieß er, wie heißt der Franzosen Dichter, nicht Louis Vuitton, die haben doch auch so
einen ganz bekannten, Francois, Francois, wie heißt denn der, Francois, wie schreibt man
das, Francois, aber die Francois heißt die alle, den meine ich, den meine ich, der ist
auch voll bekannt bei den Franzosen, den gibt es aber, wenn du den Kram bis liest,
dann hast du auch keinen Plan, ja auch wenn du Native Speaker bist, wurde gerade das Renton
Video angeschaut, was, nein, ah die Musik hier, Pepejam, ich weiß, dass er nicht Louis Vuitton
heißt, mir ist der echte Name nicht eingefallen, möchte uns eigentlich, nein, nein, ich klick
da nicht drauf, ich, ich darf, ich muss mir angewöhnen Leute, auf solche Hashtags, solche
Hashtags, solche Hashtags, das da, das da, das da, das da, das da, da darf ich alles
immer draufklicken, weil dann reg ich mich nur auf und, und zweifel immer an dem Verstand
der Leute, da, da, ich darf, Keks, das ist, das ist ein, das ist ein guter Trend in Germany,
muss ich sagen, oder, oder ist es eher Keks, vielleicht ist es auch Keks, außerdem, außerdem
schreibt man das, eigentlich schreibt man das ja mittlerweile Kek W und nicht Kek S,
vielleicht ist Kek S auch die Weiterentwicklung von Kek W, ok gucken wir mal, was, was zum,
was hat das mit Keks zu tun, Leute, der was ins Auge gekriegt hat, so lange vor dem Bildschirm
sitzt das nicht gut, nä, sowas ist nicht Monkertoss, ihr wisst doch, das ist Kokona-Plattform,
wenn ich zeige wie Leute, äh, das Gesicht eingeschlagen wird im Stream ist kein Problem,
aber wehe mal der Nippel erscheint irgendwo, regular expressions regex in 100 sec, nein,
das, das muss zum Einschlafen wirklich nicht sein, Wissenschaftler in der Corona-Krise,
ich verstehe gar nicht, warum so viele, der Typ hat so viel, so viel Hate auf sich gezogen,
was mir komplett unverständlich ist, komplett unverständlich, Programmiersprachen-Quest
zum Einschlafen, hast du Link, hast du Link zum Programmiersprachen-Quest, ist der bekannt,
Justin L-I-T-E, kenn ich nicht, der Lego M-M-M-2-46, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
das ist das beste Einschlafvideo, how to basic, how to remove virus from computer, wo ist
das Ei, wo ist das Ei, der ist so fertig, der Dömer, der ist so fertig, der Dömer,
der Dömer, der ist so fertig, der Dömer, der Dömer, der Dömer, der Dömer, die Dömer,
der ist so fertig
du du du du du du
das ist doch das kennen wir doch alle schon
das kennen wir doch alle schon das ist doch wirklich nichts neues das ist doch das ist
doch old school das ist das ist er sieht das ohne irgendwas dabei
jungler jungler jungler ich habe keine ahnung was jungler heißt aber das sagt er an der
stelle immer
Schankler und der Bañador.
Ich bin auf der Flasche, da ist die Mare.
Und du?
Und du? Und du? Kommt auch rüber. Und du?
Ich habe die Mare mit einem Doppelmaß.
Hahahaha!
Habt ihr gesehen, es gibt jetzt...
Der hat noch mehr Videos. Die haben...
Die haben auch so eine komische...
So eine komische spanische Fernsehsendung mit ihm.
Ich habe letztes Mal bei YouTube nach ihm gesucht.
Die haben auch so eine komische spanische Fernsehsendung mit ihm.
Wo er quasi...
Ähm...
Darüber entscheidet, wer...
Wer quasi gewinnt so.
Da muss er belustigt werden.
Er sitzt...
Er sitzt da.
Er sitzt da und die machen halt Witze.
Und sie müssen ihn zum Lachen bringen.
Und wahrscheinlich gewinnt derjenige, der ihn zum Lachen bringt.
Keck Wade! Keck Wade!
Der ist nicht witzig.
Der Typ scheint nicht witzig zu sein.
Ein Keck Wade!
Oh man!
Äh, was haben wir hier?
Hello World, wo war's?
Hello World Quiz... Oh Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Wir gucken jetzt mal ganz schnell ins Hello World Quiz rein.
Guess Programming Language bei Hello World Quiz.
Oh, das ist gut, das gefällt mir.
Play!
Ah, das ist Shakespeare oder wie das heißt?
Shakespeare.
Äh...
Coffee Script?
Was sagt ihr, Chat?
Ich tendiere zu Coffee Script.
Coffee Script?
Excellent.
Aber war das jetzt richtig?
Das ist Haskill, oder?
Haskill?
Was?
Idris.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Äh...
Was?
Idris.
Äh...
Das ist The Sampler.
Oh fuck!
Das können alle drei sein.
Common Lisp?
Ich sag mal Common Lisp.
Aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das können alle drei sein.
Also vor allem die ersten zwei könnten sein.
Ich sag Common Lisp.
Ha, richtig.
Das ist C.
Ähm...
Postscript?
Arc?
Also Klammern?
Klammern könnte Lisp sein.
Lisp hat immer Klammern.
Aber ich hab ehrlich...
Also ich tendiere ja zu Common Lisp.
Einfach weil es Klammern hat.
Aber es könnte auch Arc sein.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was Arc ist.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Also es ist weder Javaske...
Lua, ja.
Ähm...Package.
Das sieht nach Java aus.
Wobei ich mir bei dem Package nicht sicher bin.
Ob das Java ist.
Es sieht aber voll Java Style aus.
Wobei war Text?
Es könnte vielleicht sogar ActionScript sein.
Flash?
Ja das ist ActionScript.
Das ist ActionScript.
Klaas, der Fellow.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich Alexia.
Ach fucker.
Äh...
Das sieht nach C aus.
Ah!
Das könnte auch C sein.
Next.
ECL.
Super Kool leider.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung.
Und ich hab von Super Kool leider noch nie was gehört.
Super Kool leider.
Alles klar.
Äh...
Begin End.
Das sieht so ein bisschen nach Pascal aus.
Pascal?
H.
O.
O.M.G.
O.M.G.Roffel.
Oh fuck.
HQ9 plus.
Was?
Aber die Seite ist gut.
Das Spiel wird das nächste Mal nochmal weiter.
Excellent.
Great Language Game.
So Leute.
Ich geh ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Vielleicht.
Versprechen kann ich ja nichts.
Bis denn.
Ach ja.
Ich guck mal was.
Wie viele Leute haben mich eigentlich heute deabonniert.
Und entfollowed.
Weil ich Modern Warfare gestreamt hab.
Ok. Keiner zum Glück.
Hier.
11431.
Ok. Twitch.
Roblox.
Wieso sollte man?
Weil ich ja mittlerweile nicht mehr
für unbedingt Gaming Sachen bekannt bin.
Musik.
komplette anzahl
nein die die richtige komplette anzahl
warum ist dies warum machen die eigentlich die layouts immer nur
beschissener anstatt besser
also eins eins vier drei drei habe ich angeblich jetzt
ich hab sogar zwei follower plus gemacht
dit dit dit dit dit dit dit dit
warum machen sie eigentlich die die die die die layouts immer schlechter
ok leute bis morgen machts gut
zu shop bis dann